Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von der ESA und dem DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die zweite Ausgabe und damit aber auch die erste Ausgabe, die jetzt wirklich sich ganz konkret mit den technischen Abläufen in der Raumfahrt befassen möchte. Jetzt steht ja also hier eine lange Serie an, die vor allem auch mal den Weg ins All aufzeigen soll in ihren verschiedenen Phasen. Und ja, da steht es uns gut zu Gesicht, auch ganz vorne anzufangen, nämlich in dem Bereich der Missionsplanung. Wie kommt man denn sozusagen überhaupt zu seinen Aufgaben? Und als Gesprächspartner für diese Sendung begrüße ich Markus Landgraf. Ja, du bist hier, also vielleicht erst mal sagen, wo wir sind. Wir befinden uns in Darmstadt beim ESOC, dem European Space Operations Center, einem von verschiedenen Standorten der ESA. Ist ja nicht der einzige, den es gibt, aber ist so einer der größeren.
Ist der zweitgrößte von jetzt, Anzahl der Mitarbeiter, wie sind hier so 700. Und ist der zweitgrößte Standort der ESA.
Und was sind die anderen?
Also das größte Institut ist unser ESTEK, unser European Space Technology Center, in der Nähe von Amsterdam. Und da arbeiten natürlich deutlich mehr, das sind, glaube ich, 2000 Mitarbeiter. Ich weiß es nicht so genau, ich müsste es nachgucken, aber das ist sehr groß. Wenn man da mal hinkommt, das haut einen schon um. Da muss man mit dem Fahrrad von einem Ende zum anderen fahren.
Gibt es sonst noch was?
Ja, da gibt es noch eine Menge. Wir haben natürlich einen Hauptquartier, das sitzt, wie für die meisten Interregierungsorganisationen in Paris. Paris, die heimliche Hauptstadt der Welt. Und da sitzen unsere Headquarters, da sitzen so 70 Mitarbeiter in der Kante. Da sitzt auch unser Generaldirektor, natürlich. Und da werden so die programmatischen Vorgaben, politische und programmatische Vorgaben, werden dort definiert. Dann haben wir noch ein Zentrum für den wissenschaftlichen Betrieb. Das ist das ESOC, das European Science and Astronomy Center, in Villafranca bei Madrid. Da in der Nähe ist auch natürlich eine Bodenstation. Dann gibt es noch kleinere Zentren, wie zum Beispiel seit neuestem auch im Vereinigten Königreich, in der Gegend von Oxford, Harwell. Dort gibt es seit letztem Jahr ein Establishment, ein kleines oder ein Büro, das wir betreiben. Und dann haben wir auch Standorte über die ganze Welt verteilt. Es gibt auch ein kleines Büro in Washington, wo wir mit unseren amerikanischen Partnern das Interface pflegen, in Moskau natürlich auch. Es gibt eine ganze Menge Standorte. Die ESA ist eigentlich eine globale Organisation. Es ist keine nur europäische, sondern eigentlich schon global aufgestellt.
Aber sie hat natürlich ihren Schwerpunkt in Europa und dort findet die meiste Entwicklung und Tätigkeit statt. Absolut. So eben auch hier in Darmstadt beim ESOC, also dem Operation Center, da wo es vor allem darum geht, die Missionen sowohl zu planen, als auch zu leiten.
Ja, beides machen wir hier. Also das liegt einfach auch an der Tatsache, dass der Betrieb, also was man nachher vielleicht jetzt mal schon ein bisschen im Vorgriff dann macht, bei der Steuerung von so einem Vehikel, sehr eng mit dem verknüpft ist, was wir in der Planung machen. Es ist klar, dass wenn man eine Mission plant, die nicht gehen kann, dann hilft alle Kunsthandwerk beim Betrieb nichts, das Ding geht einfach einen Bach runter. Um es mal positiv zu sagen, je besser wir die Mission planen, umso optimaler lässt die sich nachher betreiben. Daher diese eigentlich untrennbare Dualität zwischen Betrieb und Planung.
Und vor allem auch wenn es später mal irgendwelche unvorhergesehenen Ereignisse gibt in der Durchführung, muss man ja im Prinzip dasselbe Know-how auch wieder an Start bringen, was man schon bei der Planung gehabt hat.
Absolut, das sind wir ja auch bekannt hier im ESOC, dass wenn mal was schief geht und wie das so ist, bei Sachen so im Grenzbereich, Projekten im Grenzbereich, da geht mal was schief und dann muss man spontan planen. Das ist Teil des Betriebs, dass man dann spontan plant und da sind wir dann von der Planungsabteilung wieder gefragt. Und die ESOC, die hatten eine ganz gute Liste von Missionen, die gerettet wurden mit dieser Methode. Und es kommen teilweise sogar international japanische, japanische Raumfahrtorganisationen kam zum ESOC, um von uns einen Satelliten retten zu lassen. Also daran sieht man schon, dass wir global eigentlich auch einen Ruf haben.
Mit dieser Methode, also ist das sozusagen jetzt ein spezielles, was heißt das mit dieser, also gibt es da ein spezieller Ablauf, der sich jetzt hier herausgebildet hat?
Ja, diese Methode, die ich da so ein bisschen verklausuliert habe, das ist praktisch diese Verquickung von Planung und Betrieb. Also traditionell ist das eigentlich mehr getrennt. Wenn man zum Beispiel ans JPL guckt, das ist ein NASA-Institut, da gibt es wirklich eine Planungsabteilung und die hat wirklich auch mit dem Kontrollzentrum gar nichts zu tun. Und die haben natürlich dann einen größeren Widerstand darin, dann das wieder zu reaktivieren, diese Planung wieder neu zu machen. Und bei uns ist das wirklich ein kurzer Weg vom Betrieb zur Planungsabteilung und das hilft natürlich unheimlich. Da kann man wirklich eine komplett neue Mission auf die Beine stellen.
Verstehe. Da sollten wir jetzt vielleicht auch mal grundsätzlich erst mal erklären, was eigentlich deine Abteilung hier ist. Sind ja schon ein paar Stichworte gefallen. Missionsplanung, Missionsanalyse. Was ist jetzt genau der Bereich, wo du zugeteilt bist?
Also ich bin hier in der Arbeitsgruppe für Missionsanalyse heißt das. Heißt auch im Englischen einfach Mission Analysis. In Europa haben wir ja unser schönes Euro-English. Das pflegen wir auch. Das ist eine Verquickung von Französisch, Deutsch und Englisch. Mission Analysis ist eine Tätigkeit zur Planung von Missionen, zur Optimierung von Flugbahnen und zur Prinzip Definition des Missionsablaufs. Das ist das, was Missionsanalyse ist. Wir sind hier organisatorisch untergeordnet in das Bodensegment und da wieder in diesem Bereich Betriebsdirektorat. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen paradox. Ich habe es ja gerade erklärt, wir sind eigentlich nicht betrieblich. Wir sind Planung, aber wir sind eben in diesem Betriebsdirektorat.
Sonst ist es halt miteinander verwoben.
Genau, es ist so ein Netzwerk. Und da in der Abteilung eben Missionsanalyse. Und die Aufgaben, die wir da haben, sind eben genau diese. Nämlich also die Anforderungen zu nehmen, die wir bekommen und dann das umzusetzen in der Mission.
Betrieb, also Operations ist ja hier der Begriff. Und die Abteilung heißt dann Ground Segment.
Also es gibt bei uns, ESA hat eine ganz klare Hierarchie. Fangen wir mal von oben an. Wir haben hier den Direktor für Betrieb, das ist das Operations Directorate. Dann gibt es darunter ein Department, das heißt Ops G, also Operations Ground Segment. Und dann gibt es unter dem Department eine Division, also eine Unterabteilung, das ist Ops GF, das ist die Division for Flight Dynamics in the Ground Segment Department. Und dann haben wir noch Ops GFA, das ist dann meine Sektion. Da sind wir so acht Leute, acht bis zehn Leute, die machen dann eben genau diese Missionsanalyse. Und GFA bedeutet Mission Analysis in the Division of Flight Dynamics in the Department of Ground Segment. Also das ist schon so eine Pyramide, so eine Hierarchie da. Die hat natürlich auch ihren Sinn und Zweck, weil dadurch sind klare Kommunikationsschnittstellen gegeben. Wenn ich zum Beispiel jetzt mit meinem Kollegen in Ops O sprechen möchte, Ops O ist dann das Department für den Betrieb selber. Und dann weiß ich, wo ich hin muss. Da gehe ich ins Büro von meinem Chef, von meinem Chef, von meinem Chef, dessen Unterarbeiter, dessen Unterarbeiter. Das ist wie so ein schöner algorithmischer Baum. Dann kann man sich hoch und wieder runter hangeln und dann weiß man, mit wem man sprechen muss.
Ja, aber man redet auch sozusagen direkt zu der Gruppe und nicht jetzt über 50 Mittelsmännern und so weiter. Nein, nein, nein, das würde nicht gehen. Nee, das würde wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren. Ja, okay, das heißt, worum es geht, ist sozusagen die Planung. Weil ich meine, was man sich wahrscheinlich selten klarmacht, also insbesondere jetzt in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung, beginnen ja solche Projekte mit dem Start. Ich war so, ja, die ESA, die hat da jetzt den Satelliten hochgeschossen. Da sieht man dann so von seinem geistigen Auge schon so ein paar Wissenschaftler, die vorher in den Satellitensupermarkt fahren, sich da irgendwie das richtige Modell aus dem Regal nehmen, reinlegen. Und dann wirft man das in die Rakete rein und drückt auf Go. So ist es natürlich nicht, sondern die Vorbereitungszeit bestimmt ja im Prinzip alles.
Ja, im Prinzip ist auch die Vorbereitungszeit das, was den Wert der Mission darstellt. Und wir sind typischerweise so von ersten Idee bis zum Start so zehn Jahre am machen. Und wenn man mal ausrechnet so ein Team von 1000 Ingenieure über zehn Jahre bezahlt, dann kommt man dann auf die Gehälter, bestimmen im Prinzip dann auch die Missionskosten. Dann sind wir halt einfach schon mal bei 100 Millionen in der Kante. Und deswegen ist auch die Wahrnehmung falsch, dass wenn mal ein Start misslinkt, dass dann irgendwie hunderte Millionen von Euro vernichtet wurden. Das ist natürlich Quatsch. Die sind natürlich noch vorhanden, der Wert. Nur ist diese eine Satellit, der da gebaut wurde, der dann vielleicht in der Größenordnung zehn Millionen kostet. Natürlich ist nicht billig, aber der ist zerstört.
Der muss dann halt noch mal gebaut werden. Wie das jetzt zum Beispiel passiert ist im Falle von Kryosat. Dem Erdbeobachtungssatelliten, der die Polarkappen da vermessen soll, der ist, was war das? Das war ein Softwarefehler in der Rakete, glaube ich. Leider hops gegangen, aber wurde jetzt vor kurzem erfolgreich ein zweites Mal gestartet. Und jetzt ist das Projekt sozusagen in der Spur.
Richtig, genau. Der Satellit sieht identisch so aus, ein bisschen modifizieren musste man da, wenn andere Rakete genommen haben. Und dann ist im Prinzip nichts verloren nach so einem Startfehlversuch. Nur eben direkt die Hardware, die verloren gegangen ist, die Rakete und der Satellit.
Was mich jetzt mal interessieren würde, ist, eigentlich würde ich sogar gerne noch ein bisschen weiter zurückgreifen. Weil klar, wenn solche Missionen starten, ist klar, da muss man dann viele Wissenschaftler zusammentrommeln, da wird irgendwie alles durchgerechnet, etc. Das werden wir ja auch gleich noch mal näher anschauen. Aber wie kommt es denn überhaupt erst mal zu diesen Missionen? Also wie ergibt sich, dass man einen Cryosat starten will? Wie ergibt sich, dass man eine Raumsonde zu einem Kometen planen möchte? Was sind sozusagen die Dynamiken, die da vorher stattfinden müssen?
Genau, da bist du in einem sehr interessanten Mysterium auf der Spur. Da sind wir in Europa und überall auf der Welt läuft das so. Werden diese Missionen als Ideen entstehen in dem kollektiven Gedanken einer wissenschaftlichen Community? Da gibt es Communities, z.B. die Erdbeobachtungsexperten oder die Klimawissenschaftler oder die Geologen, die sich für den Mars interessieren. Die treffen sich natürlich regelmäßig auf Konferenzen, diskutieren ihre Arbeit, so funktioniert Naturwissenschaft. Und dann sagt einer, wir haben hier diese Daten fehlen und wir können einfach ohne diese Daten nicht weiter. Und dann, wie kommen wir an die Daten? Da müssen wir eigentlich aus dem Weltraum beobachten. Manchmal kann man es auch auf dem Boden ausmachen. Bei Erdbeobachtung ist das durchaus möglich, mit dem Flugzeug drüber zu fliegen, gar kein Thema. Aber bei der Marsgeologie kommt man nicht drumhin, Bilder zu machen oder Proben zu nehmen oder chemische Analysen oder mit einem Teleskop drauf zu gucken. Diese Idee ist so ein bisschen wie Ideen, die man selbst so hat. Ich glaube, meine Idee von meinem Kopf ist, dass in meinem Kopf irgendwas kocht. Der Tropfen, der beim Kochen am höchsten springt, ist der, der dann irgendwann in mein Bewusstsein ankommt. Also wie so ein kochendes Brei, stelle ich mir meinen Kopf vor. Und so ist das da auch. Das ist wirklich so. Die kommen mit allen möglichen Ideen. Und da gibt es schon mal eine Vorauswahl einfach dadurch, dass die Community sagt, was macht eigentlich Sinn? Was ist nicht total verrückt? Was ist machbar? Was könnte man denken? Und die kommen dann, oft haben die schon durch ihre institutionellen Kontakte, Beziehungen zur ESA. Die fragen dann auch, ruf mal, mein Doktorvater ist zum Beispiel nach wie vor in seiner Community tätig. Der ruft mich auch mal an, der sagt Markus, hör mal zu, wir haben da eine Idee, kann man sowas fliegen im Prinzip? Da wird das vorher schon mal ein bisschen abgeklopft. Und dann gibt es natürlich den formalen Weg, dass wir in den Wissenschaftsprogrammen der ESA regelmäßig Call for Proposals machen, heißt das. Also einen Aufruf, Vorschläge einzureichen. Und dann kommen die Wissenschaftler formal mit einem langen Brief, in dem die Missionsanforderungen formuliert sind. Ich sag mal, ich mach mal ein schönes Beispiel. Ein Geologe will wissen, ob Gips auf dem Mars gibt. Und sein Hintergrund ist der, er weiß, dass Gips auf der Erde entsteht durch heiße Quellen. Heiße Quellen sind dafür bekannt, dass dort Lebewesen sich tummeln, nach Bakterien. Und die Analogie möchte er ziehen. Und er wüsste gern, ob es diese Thermalquellengeologie auch auf dem Mars mal heute gibt oder mal gegeben hat. Und er erkennt aus seinem Labor die spektrale Signatur von Gips. Man hätte gern mit einem Infrarotspektrometer, würde er gern gewisse Bereiche auf dem Mars fotografieren unter einem gewissen Beleuchtungswinkel. Und dann wird zum Beispiel gesagt, okay, wir würden gern diese Messung machen und schlägt eine Mission vor. Dann fliegen wir zum Mars, gehen vielleicht in Umlaufbahn, wir wissen nicht welche, aber wir müssen diese Beleuchtungsbedingungen haben und möchten da so und so viele Bilder machen über einen gewissen Zeitraum mit der und der spektralen Auflösung. Und dieser Vorschlag wird dann eben besprochen und da gibt es viele von diesen Vorschlägen für jedes Programm und da gibt es ein Gremium in der ESA, das nennt sich SPC, Science Program Committee und das SPC entscheidet praktisch, welche Vorschläge überhaupt studiert werden im Rahmen der ESA. Und dann kommt das in die ESA Mühle und die ESA Mühle hat den Vorteil, dass sie sehr effizient ist wie jeder Mechanismus. Man dreht auf einer Seite und hinten kommt was raus. Man kann davon ausgehen, dass hinten was rauskommt. Da muss man nicht drüber nachdenken, wie machen wir das jetzt. Sondern wir machen das routinemäßig seit Jahrzehnten. Das wird dann praktisch erst mal intern in der ESA studiert. Dann wird es an unsere Industriepartner gegeben, die unter Umständen, je nachdem, in der Zukunft den Satelliten bauen müssten. Die machen dann praktisch eine Analyse dessen, was bedeutet das, wenn wir so eine Mission machen. Und dann kommt das zurück in dieses Gremium. Da wird diskutiert, welche von diesen Missionen können wir finanzieren? Der Anteil muss natürlich auch immer im Hinterkopf sein. Und wird das auch mit den Geldgebern diskutiert. Und dann wird da rausgestrichen. Missionen, die nicht so gut sind, wo die Science nicht so gut ist oder die Wissenschaft, die fliegen raus. Das ist eigentlich immer ein bisschen eine Schande. Das ist ein trauriger Prozess an der Stelle, weil die meisten Sachen, die rausfliegen, wirklich toll sind. Das zeigt eben, wie toll dann die sind, die wirklich geflogen werden. Danach kommen wir in die Phase B, nennt sich das, also Phase A war praktisch diese Vorausmal. Die Phase B ist dann eigentlich schon die Mission, die ausgewählt wurden, die dann auch fliegen sollen. Und die werden dann wirklich, also da sind wir dann voll drin in der Phase B, wo man dann wirklich spezifiziert, was nachher aussieht.
Aber es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt jeder einzelne Vorschlag mit ich möchte das und das untersuchen, zwangsläufig bedeutet, dass man dafür eine eigene Mission macht. Sondern es geht ja auch darum, verschiedene Sachen zu gruppieren und zu schauen, wo könnte das jetzt sozusagen mit realisiert werden oder wie können wir diese Missionen anpassen, um eben auch noch diesen Aspekt mit reinzunehmen. Wird das dann auch alles im Rahmen dieses Kommitees, dieses SPCs gemacht oder ist das dann eher so später die Optimierung innerhalb des Projektes, die dann noch andere Wissenschaftler quer reinholt, die vielleicht vorher gedacht haben, sie kommen gar nicht zum Zug?
Nee, das ist dann, also das ist natürlich so ein insgesamt Prozess, der so ein bisschen parallel abläuft. Aber meistens passiert das vorher. Die kennen sich natürlich alle. Der Typ, der eben das Gips, das Gips auf Mars suchen will, der kennt den, der die Morphologie verstehen will, also die Form des Geländes, der Geländestruktur und sie setzen sich auf der Konferenz zusammen, hör mal, du willst doch eine schöne Marskarte haben, kann ich nicht in meinen Spektrometer auch noch mitfliegen da drauf. Dann quatschen die zusammen und das ist so von der Zeitskala 10 Jahre oder 15 Jahre vor der Mission und dann kommen die mit einer Mission. Die kommen dann schon mit einem Vorschlag.
Also es ist sozusagen Aufgabe der Wissenschaftler, ihre Bedürfnisse so aufeinander abzustimmen, dass sie möglichst mit einheitlichem Gerät das machen können.
Richtig. Oft ist es natürlich auch so, dass SPC baut eine Mission zusammen oder kommt, da ist eine Propose, die sehen hoch, wenn wir das jetzt bauen würden in der Phase A, das ist ein Satellit, der wiegt 900 Kilo. Wir können aber 1200 Kilo zum Mars bringen. Dann macht man noch mal ein Letter of Opportunity, glaube ich heißt es, und dann kann man noch mal sagen, hier wir haben 300 Kilogramm frei, die zum Mars fliegen können. Wer möchte? Und dann kommen natürlich andere Leute noch rein, die vielleicht mit in der Community nicht so drin sind. Sowas gibt es natürlich auch. Man stopft die Dinger wirklich voll bis zum Rand, bis wirklich da jedes Gramm ausgenutzt ist.
Wenn man schon mal fliegt. Das ist immer ganz gut, auch so ein paar Beispiele zu beleuchten. Was sind denn so Projekte, die jetzt so in den letzten Jahren da diese wesentlichen Hürden genommen haben? Also würde da jetzt zum Beispiel Rosetta einfallen, also die Raumsonde, die Kometen untersuchen kann. Ist das ein gutes Beispiel für diesen Prozess?
Absolut, ja. Das ist so ein bisschen ein typisches Beispiel, Rosetta. Weil Rosetta ist eine Mission, die ist auch ein bisschen entstanden aus einer Vorgeschichte. Also es war so, es gab schon eine Mission, die hieß Giotto und die ist am Halley vorbeigeflogen. Und Giotto war damals in 80er Jahren oder es ging halt dann in 60er Jahren eigentlich schon los, dass man sagte, wir wissen, 1986 wird dieser Komet Halley ins innere Sonnensystem vorstoßen. Es soll internationale Flotte von Raumfahrzeugen geben, die den untersuchen. Und damals gab es eben dann diese Giotto-Mission, hat ein tolles Bild gemacht vom Kometenkern. Und als Giotto rum war, kannten die sich natürlich alle, die Wissenschaftler, die Leute, die praktisch diese fantastischen Entdeckungen gemacht haben.
Also viele Jahre auch eng zusammengearbeitet.
Richtig, genau. Und dann sagten die, oh Mensch, jetzt haben wir das. Und natürlich, wie das so ist, jeder, der mal Naturwissenschaft gemacht hat, weiß, wenn man anfängt, irgendwo zu bohren, dann tauchen neue Fragen auf. Und da war das auch so. Und jetzt, aha, wir hätten gerne eine Probe von so einem Kometenkern, war die ursprüngliche Idee. Und deswegen sollte Rosetta dann, da auch der Name so ein bisschen, den Schlüssel bieten für das, was wir mit den Teleskopen und mit Giotto gesehen haben, so praktisch diese Mysterien aufschließen. So entstand die ursprüngliche Idee. Das wurde dann in der Zeit abgewandelt. Man hat dann die Idee aufgegeben, Proben zurückzubringen, sondern hat eine andere Strategie gefahren, nämlich ein kleines robotisches Labor auf die Oberfläche des Kometenkerns zu bringen. Das hört sich erstmal teurer an, ist aber nicht so, weil man spart natürlich den Treibstoff für den Rückflug. Und das hat man dann realisiert und das ist jetzt auch das, was wir machen. Und das ging auch so, da gab es dann genau wie ich gesagt habe, diesen Call for Proposals, da wurden dann Instrumente vorgeschlagen, da gab es ein Instrument, das macht ein Bild von dem Kometenkern, da gibt es ein Instrument, das macht ein Infrarotspektrum, da gibt es ein Instrument, also ein Gerät, das landet auf der Oberfläche und das Gerät trägt zum Beispiel einen chemischen Analyseapparat, so ein kleines chemisches Labor, dann gibt es eine große Antenne, die funkt durch den Kern durch, um dann die Veränderung des Funksignals, gibt Auskunft über die innere Struktur, also lauter ganz spannendes Instrument. Die wurden alle zusammengesammelt und geguckt, aha, wie kriegt man das zusammen zu einer Mission? Und dann wurde das studiert. Damals gab es noch keine concurrent design facility, das ist unsere Keimzelle für die Mission am Anfang, aber es wurde intern in der ESA studiert, was bedeutet das eigentlich. Und da war auch meine Abteilung dann schon involviert. Da wurde dann gefragt, wie kommt man, welche Rakete müssen wir nehmen? Wir wollen zu diesen Kometen. Wir kannten den Kometen, damals hieß der Wirthanen, kannten die Umlaufbahn von dem Ding. Und wie kommen wir dahin?
Wo heißt der jetzt nicht mehr so?
Der heißt immer noch so, aber zu dem sind wir nicht geflogen. Wir haben dann leider eine Startgelegenheit verpasst. Dann mussten wir die nächste nehmen. Dann konnten wir zum Wirthanen nicht mehr fliegen, sondern jetzt sind wir dann zum Churyumov-Gerasimenko geflogen. Der hat etwas andere Eigenschaften, aber das geht auch. Im Endeffekt wissen wir über Churyumov-Gerasimenko genauso wenig, wie wir über Wirthanen wissen. Von daher ergibt sich da kein großer Unterschied. So ist dann die Rosetta-Mission irgendwann in der Phase B gelandet, wo wir sie dann natürlich definiert haben in der Missionsanalyse-Abteilung.
Also Phase A ist sozusagen, man sammelt alles zusammen, was man testen möchte. Man einigt sich auf die konkreten Geräte, die auf dem Satelliten untergebracht werden sollen. Und natürlich dann auch die Details, wer die baut, etc. Und dann kommt Phase B. Das ist sozusagen, es steht schon fest, man will das tun. Es steht schon fest, womit. Daraus ergibt sich auch schon, welche Rakete man letzten Endes nehmen möchte. Und da ist aber jetzt der Satellit noch nicht beauftragt in dem Sinne, oder?
Also jetzt vom Industriepolitischen her ist es so, dass an der Stelle die Phase A heutzutage parallel durchgeführt wird. Das heißt, die im Wettbewerb stehenden Unternehmen, die Lieferanten, die uns die Satelliten liefern, die sind in der Studienphase oder in der Definitionsphase, also in der Phase A, also machen die parallele Studie. Jeder macht für sich, das hört sich erst mal nach Verschwendung von Geldern an, hat aber den gegenteiligen Effekt dadurch, dass jeder mit einem Konzept kommt und versucht natürlich den großen Aufdreiß. Das große Geld fließt ja dann nachher. Beim Bau der Satelliten fließt ja das Geld nachher. Und dann legen die sich natürlich unheimlich ins Zeug, dafür das beste Konzept zu haben. Und das hat sich natürlich als sehr effizient herausgestellt, weil natürlich der Wettbewerb hilft dabei, das optimal zu gestalten. Und dann die Phase B liegt eben auch gleich mit fest. Dann der Übergang von Phase A zur Phase B ist dann hochpolitisch. Dann wird der Lieferant ausgewählt. Und das ist natürlich gerade in Europa immer so ein Thema. Wo ist der jetzt angesiedelt? Ist das ein britisches Unternehmen, ein französisches oder ein deutsches oder ein italienisches?
Jetzt haben wir schon drei Franzosen, jetzt brauchen wir auch noch mal.
Ja, so in die Richtung. Das ist natürlich auch nicht ganz falsch, weil der Vorteil, das nennt sich dann Geographical Return, da wird dann darauf Wert gelegt, dass Deutschland bezahlt, zum Beispiel 22% des ESA-Budgets im Moment und 22% der Aufträge im Geldvolumen wieder nach Deutschland gehen. Das heißt also 90% des Geldes, das Deutschland einzahlt, kommt nach Deutschland zurück. Na gut, 10% sind immer overhead. Man muss natürlich auch die Ingenieure bezahlen, die in der ESA arbeiten, die diese Sache koordinieren. Und dann baut eben zum Beispiel Astrium Friedrichshafen oder Astrium in Bremen oder auch das DLR in Lampolzhausen kann auch ein Auftragnehmer sein oder OHB kann man da nennen. In Deutschland, in Frankreich könnte man da zum Beispiel Astrium Toulouse nennen oder Ariane Spass natürlich jetzt beim Launcher. Dann gibt es Snackma, die ist die Firma, die baut die kleinen Düstchen, Reaction Control System und so weiter. Da gibt es eine ganze Latte von Lieferanten, die eben entweder als Hauptauftragnehmer oder als Unterauftragnehmer auftreten können. Und da ist es natürlich für unsere, wenn wir neue Programme haben wollen, neues Geld, ist natürlich unheimlich für uns ein starkes Argument zu sagen, Leute, hört zu. Im Endeffekt machen wir eine intelligente Subvention für euch. Ihr habt zwei Sachen davon. Eure Industrie bekommt Geld und zweitens bekommt Know-how. Und zwar in einem Rahmen von einem Projekt, was Sinn macht, wo nachher auch gute Wissenschaft daraus kommt. Und deswegen ist das manchmal in diesem Übergang Phase A, Phase B, ist dann eben sehr politisch. Wird eben auf diesen Geographical Return geguckt. Wenn zum Beispiel jetzt ein Projekt ist, wo Deutschland großen Beteiligung hat, dann wird eben geguckt, dass es auch nach Deutschland geht. Und wenn das dann entschieden ist, dann können die erst richtig Vollgas geben, dann fließt auch Geld, dann fangen die wirklich an, da fliegen dann die Aluminiumspäne und dann geht's los.
Phase A, Phase B, wie viele Phasen müssen wir jetzt hier durchschreiten, um diesen Prozess abzubilden?
Bis eh, ne. Also CDE, es würde mal als eine Phase so genannt. Also aus meiner Perspektive ist CDE so hinten dran. Ich kriege da kaum was von mit. A und B sind für mich eigentlich relevant.
Okay, also A ist sozusagen Bestimmung, was soll Umfang sein, was soll letzten Endes auf den Satelliten drauf oder auf die Raumsonde oder was halt jetzt auch konkret da ins All geschickt werden soll. Und B ist sozusagen die Phase, in der das dann alles festgezurrt wird. Und wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger parallel wird dann auch bestimmt, wer jetzt was wie wann konkret baut. Oder ist das sozusagen dann der Abschluss von Phase A, dass das dann auch schon feststeht, dass man jetzt auch wirklich weiß schon, womit man es zu tun hat?
Also der Abschluss von Phase A ist dann, da ist dann der Prime Contractor gewählt. Also im Prinzip der Hauptauftragnehmer. Und dann kommt natürlich während der Phase B, kommt dann diese Procurement Phase, nennt sich das. Dann wird der Hauptauftragnehmer gebeten, sich Lieferanten zu suchen für gewisse Subsysteme. Da geht dann zum Beispiel UHB los und sucht sich jemanden, der einen Solarpanel bauen kann für den Satelliten. Und die müssen natürlich dann auch wieder eine Ausschreibung machen. Die müssen die günstigsten oder besten Lieferanten auswählen, unter Aufsicht der ESA. Und das Gute daran ist natürlich, dass die Leute von UHB natürlich die industrielle Landschaft sehr gut kennen, weil sie selbst zur Industrie gehören. Und wir als ESA haben die andere Sicht. Wir sehen eben unsere Anforderungskatalog, wir haben ja aufgeschrieben, was das Ding können muss. Und dann praktisch, um drauf zu gucken, dass tatsächlich nicht nur das Billigste genommen wird, weil die dürfen und müssen ja ihren Profit maximieren, die Hauptauftragnehmer, aber sie dürfen es eben nicht so weit treiben, dass das Ding nachher nicht das kann, was wir wollen. Das ist ganz wichtig dabei. Und das wird auch dadurch sichergestellt, dass diese Phasen, die Schnittstellen dieser Phasen, sind auch oft oder in diesen Phasen eingestreut sind, die sogenannten Reviews, die sind ganz wichtig. Das sind also diese Begutachtung des Status Quo. Da gibt es jetzt mal das Ende der Phase A, ist der System Requirements Review, also die Begutachtung der Systemanforderungen. Und in der Phase B haben wir dann zum Beispiel den Critical Design Review, wo praktisch das Design, das festgezurrt wurde, überprüft wird vis-à-vis den Anforderungskatalog, den man am Anfang mal aufgestellt hatte. Und dann gibt es dann später noch ein Flight Readiness Review, ist praktisch der Abschluss der Phase B. Das heißt, am Ende von Phase B ist man bereit zum Fliegen. Das sind so die großen, da gibt es immer noch kleinere Reviews dazwischen. Und in diesem Rahmen wird auch getestet. Da gibt es zum Beispiel dann im S-Tag eine große Thermalvakuumkammer. Da wird das ganze Ding, wenn es fertig gebaut ist, reingesteckt, Luft rausgelassen und dann wird das Ding im Vakuum Sonnenlicht oder Sonnenstrahlung exponiert, also simulierten Sonnenstrahlung, weil man kann ja da in der Hülle keinen Licht reinlassen. Und dann wird mal geguckt, wo sich das Ding aufheizt und ob das alles so funktioniert auch noch unter diesen Bedingungen. Und dann wird es dann auch noch geschüttelt, weil das muss man simulieren, wie es sich in der Rakete verhält und so weiter. Und dann wird natürlich ganz einfach überprüft, wir haben diese Anforderung, das Ding muss zum Beispiel in Ariane 5 starten können und wir kennen das Schüttelprofil von Ariane 5. Dann schütteln wir es genauso, wie es beim Start geschüttelt werden würde. Und wenn es auseinanderbricht, dann durchgefallen, zack, nochmal neu machen.
Da wird dann aber auch schon wirklich sozusagen an dem einen tatsächlichen Satellit, der wird getestet oder werden da so Prototypen gebaut, die dann erst mal in etwa...
Das ist mit so einem Mischmasch geworden. Es gibt... Als früher gab es ein Flight-Model. Das war die Hardware, die nachher wirklich flog. Und es gab ein... Und mittlerweile testet man aber auch das Ding, das selber fliegt nachher. Da muss man natürlich bei den Tests aufpassen, dass es nicht überstrapaziert wird. Und das fließt so ineinander über. Das evolviert mit der Zeit.
Aber so ein Engineering Model wird auch immer noch hergestellt, damit man sozusagen, wenn der andere im Alles, immer noch einen zum Anfassen und zum Vergleichen hat.
Richtig, auch im Betrieb auch. Durchaus auch Teil des Simulators. Wir haben hier zum Beispiel im ESOC steht das Engineering Model vom Rosetta in dem Rheinraum. Und der Onboard-Computer, der da eingebaut ist, der wird auch heute noch mit Kommandos gefüttert, die wir vielleicht dann oder bestimmt oder wahrscheinlich dann zwei Tage später zum richtigen Raumfahrzeug, der sich im Weltraum befindet, schicken, um zu gucken, was würde passieren, wenn man sich das Kommando schicken. Einfach als Sicherheitstest. Und es ist ja immer so, zum Beispiel der Onboard-Computer, der wird sehr stark benötigt während der Entwicklungsphase. Bei den verschiedenen Tests muss eigentlich immer der Onboard-Computer da sein. Das heißt, es gibt meistens zwei oder drei Onboard-Computer, die identisch sind. Und der eine ist halt bei dem Test, der andere ist bei dem Test. Und deswegen hat man natürlicherweise immer schon zwei, drei Versionen von dem Ding.
Aber bevor wir jetzt so sehr in diese Operationsphase abgeleiten, lassen wir uns nochmal so ein bisschen bei den Vorbereitungen bleiben. Fassin, ist es sinnvoll, jetzt noch bei Rosetta als Beispiel einfach zu bleiben? Inwieweit warst du da bei dem Projekt mit involviert?
Da bin ich ein bisschen zu jung für. Aber ich kenne Rosetta. Das ist ja immer so in dem Gebiet, man muss erstmal verstehen, was früher gemacht wurde, um dann neue Dinge zu tun. Und Rosetta finde ich ein gutes Beispiel. Lass uns ruhig darüber reden. Also in der Phase A war man dann zu der Meinung, man würde eben diese Proben zurückholen. Man hat dann eine Flugbahn definiert, die so funktionierte, dass man mit einer Ariane 5 losflog, damals schon, das war schon die Idee, von Kourou aus unserem Weltraumbahnhof direkt auf eine Bahn, die zur Venus führte, dort Swing-By machte, also einen Vorbeiflug. Da können wir vielleicht gleich nochmal drüber reden, wie das funktioniert. Dann an der Erde vorbei, dann noch zweimal an der Venus und dann praktisch auf einen Parallelkurs raus zum Kometen.
Wo ist denn dieser Komet? Wo flog denn der so?
Also auswendig weiß ich es nicht. Das ist ein Jupiter-Typ-Komet. Das sind Kometen, die umkreisen die Sonne auf einer Bahn, die auch nicht so weit entfernt ist von ihrer Neigung her, von den Bahnen der Planeten und der Erdbahn im Besonderen. Und so typischerweise Sonnenabstände haben zwischen 0,5 und vielleicht sieben astronomischen Einheiten. Das heißt also, die sind nicht so extrem weit weg von der Sonne. Es gibt zum Beispiel der Helikomet, der kommt ja weit aus dem, der kommt ja aus der, na gut, der ist auch ein Affil, was ist denn, gibt es einen schönen Kometen, fällt mir jetzt gerade der Name nicht ein. Helbob zum Beispiel.
Also astronomische Einheit, uns vielleicht noch kurz erläutern, ist der Abstand zwischen Erde und Sonne.
Genau, der mittlere Abstand zwischen Erde und Sonne.
Genau, weil das eiert ja. Das ganze Sonnensystem eiert.
Richtig, und wenn wir das als eins nehmen?
Das heißt, der Komet halbe AE, heißt sozusagen, er nähert sich quasi bis zur Hälfte dieser Strecke an, also auf 75 Millionen Kilometer ungefähr, an die Sonne.
Und 7 AU ist draußen jenseits vom Jupiter. Die meisten Kometen kommen allerdings von ganz, ganz weit draußen, von der Orchid Wolke, dieser Helbob zum Beispiel. Die sind natürlich sehr schwer anzufliegen. Mit denen kann man kein Rendezvous machen, weil die halt so eine extreme andere Umlaufbahn haben. Und diese Jupiter-Typ Kometen, da hat man schon Hoffnung hinzufliegen. Und so machen wir es. Dann hatten wir gedacht, wir fliegen da das Rendezvous mit dem Kometen, nachdem wir ein paar Mal an den Planeten vorbei waren. Rendezvous mit dem Kometen.
Also Rendezvous heißt, dem sehr nahe kommen.
Nicht nur nahe kommen, sondern auch die Geschwindigkeit anpassen. Ganz wichtig. Dann da landen, dann Probe nehmen, wieder abheben und dann zurück zur Erde fallen und dann mit dem Hitzeschild wieder eintreten und die Bodenproben da zurück zur Erde bringen, die kommen dann ins Labor. Das war so die Idee. Und das war so unsere erste Version von der Mission.
Wobei das noch mit dem anderen Kometen war, der dann...
Genau. Richtig. Und dann kam halt dazu, dass wir erst mal gesehen haben, durch unsere Rechnung, wenn wir das machen, wird das Ding sehr schwer am Start. Man kann dann rückrechnen, okay, ich will, sag mal mal, eine Tonne Gerätschaft brauche ich auf dem Kometen, plus ein bisschen Treibstoff, ich muss ja wieder zurückkommen. Dann kann ich zurückrechnen, okay, ich habe diese Planeten-Vorbeiflüge, um zu diesen Planeten zu kommen, muss ich da ein Manöver machen, das kostet mir nicht so und so viel Treibstoff. Und das heißt, beim Start muss das Ding acht Tonnen wiegen. Acht Tonnen kann die Arianen nicht in eine Fluchtbahn befördern, geht leider nicht. Und dann, aha, Kratz, Kratz am Kopf, was machen wir? Fluchtbahn ist eine Flugbahn, die von der Erde wegführt und das Gravitationsfeld der Erde verlassen kann. Also braucht eine gewisse Geschwindigkeit, um die Erde zu verlassen, die liegt bei 11 Kilometer pro Sekunde. Dann kann man sie gerade so verlassen. Wenn man eine Umlaufbahn um die Erde will, braucht man nur knapp acht Kilometer pro Sekunde. Wenn du noch mal drei drauf tust, dann kommst du weg von der Erde und kannst zum Beispiel zur Venus fliegen oder zum Mars. Aber diese 11 Kilometer pro Sekunde reicht nicht ganz, muss ein bisschen mehr sein.
Da braucht man halt eine Menge Schub, und das war dann sozusagen der Treibstoff nicht machbar.
Richtig, ist dann eben die Machbarkeit in Fragen gestellt worden, weil man eben auch gesagt hat, wir brauchen eine Tonne da oben, damit man bohren kann und bla bla bla. Und da sagt, ja, wie können wir das leichter machen? Da gibt es natürlich eine Variante, man hat ein kleineres Labor. Dann haben wir versucht, das zu verkleinern. Und das war nicht unsere Aufgabe, sondern es ist eine Aufgabe der Wissenschaftler, zu sagen, wie können wir unsere Instrumente leichter machen? Und man kam darauf, das geht irgendwie nicht. Und dann haben wir gesagt, ja, wie wäre es denn, wenn wir gar nicht zurückfliegen müssen? Und das war dann so die Idee, die entstand in der Diskussion. Wir nehmen größeres Labor, weniger Treibstoff, mehr Labor, und fliegen halt nicht zurück, sondern wir nehmen da...
Wir nehmen nur die Ergebnisse.
Richtig, per Funk. Und das ging dann. Dann hat man dann neu gerechnet, neue Flugbahn, weil man brauchte keine Rückflugbahn mehr. Man hat dann auch akzeptiert, dass man ein bisschen länger unterwegs ist, dass man dann nochmal an der Erde vorbeifliegt. Allerdings kam dann auch schon ein Problem. Und das ist ein ganz typisches Beispiel für die Missionsanalyse. Man stellt dann plötzlich fest, Problem. Weil man nicht dran gedacht hat. Das sind solche Grenzprojekten, ist das oft so. Problem, wir können nicht zu Venus fliegen. Weil das Ding soll nachher am Kometen in Rendezvous fliegen. Und draußen beim Kometen ist es sehr kalt, weil man ist fünf AU von der Sonne weg, fünf astronomische Einheiten von der Sonne weg. Und das heißt ein paar hundert Millionen Kilometer. Und da ist es sehr kalt. Und wenn wir gleichzeitig ein Raumfahrzeug bauen wollen, das da funktioniert und bei der Venus, das geht nicht. Das können wir nicht zusammen. Das Thermaldesign davon ist unmöglich. Die Anforderungen beißen sich. Und dann hat man festgelegt, dass man nicht an der Venus vorbeifliegen darf. Und dann hat man eben die Erde um Mars vorbeiffliegen genommen. Mars ist ein bisschen ein Problem, weil er ist sehr klein im Vergleich zur Erde. Er hat deswegen nicht so viel Schwung mit. Man hat einen Design gefunden, das dauert jetzt länger. Das ist eine zehn Jahre lange Trajektorie. Auswendig weiß ich gar nicht, wie viele Vorbeiflüge jetzt notwendig sind. Ich glaube, Erde, Mars, Erde, Erde ist dann nachher rausgekommen. Ich müsste es aber nachgucken. Jedenfalls macht man jetzt mehrere Vorbeiflüge, um dann, also Start war 2004, und wir kommen jetzt 2014, kommen wir dann erst am Kometen an. Das ist halt auch so ein bisschen so ein Trade-off-Analysis, nennt sich das. Wir schlagen eine Bahn vor und dann sagen die Wissenschaftler, oh Gott, sagen die immer erst mal. Was habt ihr denn da gerechnet?
Jetzt kommen wir ja eigentlich zu so einem Kern von allen Raumerkundungsflügen vor allem. Ich meine, das ist jetzt dieselbe Arithmetik wird wahrscheinlich auch jetzt bei den orbitalen Projekten auch irgendwie mit einfließen, aber da sind die Anforderungen natürlich ganz andere, weil da ist man halt einmal im Orbit. Das ist dann so der Ort, an dem man sein will, weil das einfach die richtige Höhe ist für welches Projekt auch immer. Erdbeobachtung hat seine Anforderungen etc. Aber in dem Moment, wo man raus ins Sonnensystem möchte, um dort einfach irgendwo was zu erkunden, da ist das ja schon eine ganz trickige Geschichte, weil man weiß, der Komet fliegt ja überall auch nur einmal lang, bzw. er kommt da vielleicht irgendwann auch mal vorbei, aber das dauert dann wieder ewig. Wie lange braucht dieser Komet, bis er einmal rum ist?
Da hast du mich jetzt auf den linken Bein erwischt, das weiß ich auswendig nicht.
Zu Pin mal Daumen?
Das sind immer typischerweise zig, also ein paar Jahrzehnte.
Das kommt aber jetzt nicht alle paar Jahre vor, sondern wenn man diesen einen Vorbeiflug nicht mitnimmt, dann ist die Gelegenheit einfach erst mal vom Tisch.
Genau, also Hellay z.B., den man damals mit Giotto angeflogen hat, der kommt alle 67 Jahre wieder.
So, hätte man das Datum nicht gehalten, dann wäre es halt vorbei gewesen. Da hätte man ihn gleich wieder einpacken können. Schön, dass wir drüber gesprochen haben. Okay, jetzt muss ich nochmal kurz nachschauen, wie heißt der? Churyumov-Gerasimenko. Nach dem 10. Mal hat man es wahrscheinlich ganz gut drauf.
Uchenharaschow. Russische, zwei Russische.
Der heißt wahrscheinlich so, weil die beiden den Begriff haben.
Genau, zwei russische Astronomen, korrekt.
Könnten aber auch wirklich unkompliziertere Namen haben, die aus Russland sind.
Ich denke, Müller und Mayer werden die in Russland mit heißen.
Na ja, aber ich hätte auch TG sagen können. Wie auch immer. Also es gibt nur eine Chance. Oder es gibt vielleicht mehrere Möglichkeiten, wo man sozusagen angreift. Das ist ja auch die Frage, wo man will ja nur irgendwo da sein. Man kann ja sozusagen überall auf diesem Weg begleiten. Aber welcher Bereich kommt sozusagen überhaupt in Frage für so etwas? Wie bestimmt man denn das schon mal?
Das sind jetzt wieder die wissenschaftlichen Anforderungen. Die Wissenschaftler sagen, wir wollen den Kometen sehen, wenn er sich der Sonne nähert, sodass wir beobachten können, wie diese Aktivität entsteht. Der Komet ist ja berühmt dafür, dass er diese schöne Koma entwickelt, diesen Schweif. Den kann man am Himmel sehen, auch wenn der Kern selbst so klein ist, dass man niemals mit dem bloßen Auge sehen könnte.
Aber der entsteht ja auch erst, wenn der Sonne nah genug ist.
Der Schweif, genau. Und das war die Anforderung. Da haben die Wissenschaftler von vornherein gesagt, wir wollen das Rendezvous fliegen, wenn das Ding weit draußen ist, wenn es eben noch nicht aktiv ist.
Um den Vergleich zu haben.
Und auch wegen des Risikos. Wir wissen, die Kummer besteht aus Staubpartikeln. Staubpartikeln können auch durchaus heißen faustgroße Bröckchen, Felsen. Und wenn man da reinfliegt mit...
Also das heißt, man möchte sozusagen drauf landen, bevor das Ding anfängt, wirklich auseinander zu fliegen. Aber wenn es dann losgeht, muss man auch dabei sein, um diesen Effekt auch noch mitzuhaben.
Das ist jetzt in dem Fall eine Anforderung. Es gibt auch andere Beispiele, zum Mars zum Beispiel. Da ist eigentlich egal, ob man... Also oft ist es egal, ob man im Frühjahr oder im Herbst auf den Mars ankommt. Es gibt natürlich auch auf dem Mars, zum Beispiel im Spätsommer gibt es so eine Sturmperiode, ähnlich wie auf der Erde mit den Hurricanes. Nur auf dem Mars sind es halt Staubstürme und da möchte man da nicht ankommen. Aber eigentlich ist dem Wissenschaftler das egal. Beim Kometen ist es ganz wichtig, dass man in der richtigen Phase seines Orbits erwischt.
Vielleicht können wir ja die Mars-Missionen auch noch mal kurz im Anschluss beleuchten. Mars Express etc. waren ja auch diese Missionen. So, das heißt, man möchte, also wann in etwa geht es los mit dem Koma? Also wie nah muss der Komet der Sonne sein, dass er anfängt Bröckchen zu werfen?
Das hängt sehr vom Kometen, aber ungefähr bei einem AU, also beim Erdabstand.
Okay, also wenn er etwa auf Höhe der Erde ist. Das heißt, er fliegt bei uns rum und da wird dann aus dem Stein ein Komet. Damit ist sozusagen schon mal ganz gut definiert, wann man ihn treffen muss. Und dann muss man aber quasi die Geschwindigkeit des Kometen angenommen haben.
Richtig, das ist der wichtige Teil.
Und wie schnell ist das Ding unterwegs?
Also relativ zur Sonne sprechen wir da von 100.000 Kilometer pro Stunde. Rechnen kann man das auch. Also wir rechnen alles natürlich in Kilometer pro Sekunde. Und da kommen bei uns die Geschwindigkeit. Die Erde selbst hat ja auch eine Geschwindigkeit. Wir umkreisen die Sonne mit 30 Kilometer pro Sekunde ungefähr. Und wenn wir losfliegen, dann haben wir diese Geschwindigkeit. Und die müssen wir teilweise auch abbremsen.
Plus die 11, die man braucht, um loszukommen.
Richtig, plus die 11, die man braucht, um loszukommen.
Hat man schon mal 40, dann fehlen da noch 900 zu 1000.
Genau, so einfach kann man es nicht rechnen. Weil eben diese Planetenvorbeiflüge noch dabei sind. Also wir machen diese Swing-Bys.
Ja, aber warum? Also das Problem ist, man ist eigentlich nicht schnell genug.
Man hat die falsche Geschwindigkeit, sagen wir es mal so. Also man ist entweder zu schnell oder zu langsam. Das hängt jetzt von der Mission ab. Beim Kometen, wenn man den trifft, hat man eben eine hohe Relativgeschwindigkeit zum Kometen. Der Komet hat relativ zur Sonne eine Geschwindigkeit von 100.000 km pro Stunde. Aber wenn man eine ganz normale Flugbahn von Erde zum Kometen fliegen würde, hätte man eine Relativgeschwindigkeit von 10 km pro Sekunde. Und das geht nicht. Wenn man das abbremsen würde mit einem Raketenantrieb, würde viel zu viel Treibstoff kosten.
Das ist zu schnell dann schon. Das heißt, okay, also die Erde bewegt sich mit 30 km pro Sekunde. Wir schießen das Ding raus mit nochmal extra 11. So, dass er sozusagen in Erdlaufbahnrichtung mit 40 km pro Sekunde relativ...
Ja, man kann es ja nicht addieren. Ich muss es aufzeichnen, das kann man auf Podcast leider.
Ich versuch das nur mal so ein bisschen zu verstehen. Auf jeden Fall kommt es darauf an, wie der Komet sich zur Erde vor allem erst mal verhält. Also wie er quasi einschert. Und dann ergibt sich daraus eine relative Geschwindigkeit des Satelliten zum Kometen.
Und die muss man minimieren.
Die muss so gering sein, muss auf Null sein, damit man da wirklich landen kann. Und einfach bremsen geht nicht, weil das schon zu viel Kraft kosten würde.
Ja, also es würde einfach zu viel Treibstoff brauchen. Das heißt, es ist, glaube ich, besser über Flugbahnen zu sprechen. Also die Erde hat eine Flugbahn um die Sonne, das ist ein Kreis mit einem Radius von einer astronomischen Einheit. Und der Komet hat eine Flugbahn relativ zur Sonne. Gott sei Dank schneiden die beiden Flugbahnen sich nicht, sonst würde es irgendwann krachen. Aber jetzt müssen wir eine Verbindungsflugbahn finden, die die beiden verbindet. Und das ist unsere Aufgabe. Und jetzt ist es natürlich wichtig, dass der Punkt, wo die Flugbahn vom Satelliten, sich mit der vom Kometen schneidet, eine möglichst geringe Relativgeschwindigkeit aufbringt. Weil die müssen wir am Schluss mit unserem Raketentriebwerk aufbringen. Wir kommen praktisch auf unsere Flugbahn an. Und der Komet schneidet diese Flugbahn mit dieser Relativgeschwindigkeit. Die müssen wir dann mit dem Raketentriebwerk aufbringen. Das heißt, während der Mission wird die Flugbahn das Satelliten verändert. Und diese Umlaufbahnsveränderung erreichen wir durch die Vorbeiflüger an den Planeten. Und das funktioniert so. Wir fliegen eine Flugbahn relativ zu einem anderen Planeten. Das ist immer eine Hyperbole. Und das Gesetz von einer Hyperbole ist das, dass die Anflugsgeschwindigkeit die gleiche Größe hat wie die Abflugsgeschwindigkeit. Tim, jetzt wirst du sagen, der Markus hat doch gerade gesagt, ich will die Bahn aber verändern. Das kann ich ja dann noch gar nicht. Ich kann es doch, weil die Richtung der Geschwindigkeit ändert sich, nicht die Größe. Und dadurch relativ zur Sonne kann ich es so machen, weil sich die Geschwindigkeit des Planeten, an dem ich vorbeifliege, und die Geschwindigkeit des Raumfahrzeugs relativ zum Planeten addieren, kann ich die Geschwindigkeit relativ zur Sonne erhöhen oder erliedrigen, wie ich das will, je nachdem, wie ich meinen Vorbeiflug wähle. Und von der Energie her bedeutet das, dass ich dem Planeten ein bisschen Energie klaue oder ihm was Energie schenke. Das ist natürlich minimal, das wird man niemals messen können.
Aber im Prinzip fängt die Venus an zu eiern, wenn man drauf verleuchtet.
Ja, eigentlich ja. Also sie fängt an, etwas langsamer zu werden oder schneller. Aber die Venus wiegt in der Größenordnung 10 hoch 24 Kilogramm. Und der Satellit wiegt 8000 Kilogramm. Quatsch, 1000 Kilogramm. Also vergiss das mal, was die Venus da auch. Interessiert die Venus nicht so. Aber sie gibt uns den Schwung. An der Venus wollen wir ja gerade nicht vorbeifliegen, hat man ja gerade ausgefunden, aber die Erde.
Aber im Prinzip kann man das mit jedem Himmelskörper machen. Also vor allem natürlich die Planeten, weil das am meisten zu holen.
Richtig, je schwerer, umso besser.
Umso schwerer, umso besser. Das heißt, die Gravitation, die Masse des Planeten ist dafür ausschlaggebend, wie sehr man seine Flugbahnen ändern kann.
Richtig. Und wir wollen diese Flugbahn, wir wollen diese Vorbeiflüge so machen, dass nachher der Satellit auf einer Flugbahn ist, die praktisch identisch oder fast identisch ist wie die Flugbahn des Kometen. Aber diese Flugbahn kreuzt an so einem Rendezvous-Punkt und dann am Schluss macht es halt ein kleines Abbrems- oder Beschleunigungsmanöver je nachdem und wie man es nennen möchte. Und dann sind wir da.
Das heißt, der Clou ist, letzten Endes einen Weg zu finden und dabei so viele Haken zu schlagen, wie es eben erforderlich ist, die einerseits den Satelliten in etwa in eine ähnliche Flugbahn bringt. Und das dann eben auch noch optimalerweise in einer Geschwindigkeit, die weitgehend der Diskometen entspricht. Das heißt, am Ende nähern die sich dann in einem sehr kleinen Winkel an?
Richtig. Also wenn man die Flugbahnen, die abschließende Rendezvous-Flugbahn von Rosetta sieht, die ist praktisch identisch mit der vom Churyumov-Gerasimenko.
Ich könnte mir jetzt vorstellen, dass wenn ich jetzt mal ein GEO-Dreieck nehme und versuche diese Flugbahn auszurechnen, dass es da eine Weile dauern würde, wie kann man denn das machen? Also im Prinzip ist es ja erforderlich, die ganze Zeit das Sonnensystem durchzusimulieren.
Eigentlich ja. Also das wird natürlich alles mit Computern gemacht. Und ich fürchte, mein Schicksal ist das, wie das teile ich mit 90 Prozent der Bevölkerung. Man sitzt eigentlich den ganzen Tag vorm Computer. Aber ist ja eigentlich auch nicht so schlimm. Es gibt ja auch spannende Dinge am Computer zu tun. Und das ist so eine. Wir haben in unserem Computer numerische Simulationen vom Sonnensystem. Und wir haben auch eine numerische Simulation von der Flugbahn, vom Satelliten da drin. Jetzt haben wir natürlich beim Satelliten eine Freiheit. Bei den Planeten können wir nicht daran rumspielen. Die fliegen halt da lang, wo sie lang fliegen. Dem Satelliten können wir aber, seine Flugbahnen, da haben wir verschiedene, das nennen wir freie Parameter, die kann man wählen. Zum Beispiel die Abflugsgeschwindigkeit relativ zu Erde. Die wird natürlich definiert dadurch, was die Rakete uns gibt. Und da können wir eben dadurch die Anforderungen für die Rakete festlegen.
Das heißt, man kann sie sozusagen so minimal halten wie möglich oder wenn es angemessen ist, auch unter Umständen mit mehr Wumm.
Richtig. Aber in erster Nährung oder im ersten Schritt geben wir das komplett frei. Wir nehmen sogar an, dass wir eine unmöglich starke Rakete haben. Dann haben wir noch eine Möglichkeit, während des Flugmanövers zu machen, die nennen wir Deep Space Manöver. Das gibt uns eine zusätzliche Freiheit. Und dann planen wir praktisch und wir erzeugen eine interessante Freiheit durch den Vorbeiflug, weil wenn ich an einem Planeten vorbeifliege, kann ich praktisch da, wo ich vorbeifliege, bestimmt mir, welchen Ablenkwinkel ich habe. Ich muss also nur einen richtigen Ort zielen, relativ zum Planeten und das definiert mir die Geometrie des Vorbeiflugs. Und diese drei Sachen, Abflug, Deep Space Manöver und Flybys, sind freie Parameter. Und dann habe ich ein großes Optimierungsproblem. Und wer sich schon mal ein bisschen im Ingenieurswelt umgeguckt hat, das gibt es ganz oft. Man hat ein Problem, ein Randbedingungsproblem. Ich gehe bei A los, komme bei B an. Das sind meine Randbedingungen, die kann ich nicht verändern. Und zwischendrin habe ich irgendwelche Kontrollpunkte, wo ich freie Parameter habe. Und dann kann ich ein Optimierungssoftware drauf loslassen und sagen, hier, Software, bitte sorg dafür, dass irgendwas minimiert wird. Und da liege ich zum Beispiel fest, dass die Abfluggeschwindigkeit möglichst klein sein muss, damit meine Rakete nicht so schwer arbeiten muss. Und die Größe der Deep Space Manöver muss möglichst klein sein. Und das Abschlussmanöver zum Rendezvous muss auch möglichst klein sein.
Warum müssen die alle so klein sein?
Weil je größer die Manöver sind, umso mehr Treibstoff brauchen wir.
Also Manöver heißt immer, Raketen einsetzen und die Richtung ändern.
Genau, also entweder anfangs die Ariane 5 oder bei den Deep Space Manövern unsere kleinen Düsen, die wir mit an Bord haben. Und das müssen wir immer minimieren, die Geschwindigkeitsänderungen, die wir da brauchen. Und natürlich kann man die oft nicht auf Null setzen. Das wäre natürlich ideal. Wenn man sie auf Null setzen könnte, dann hätten wir eine natürliche Bahn gefunden, die auf natürliche Art und Weise uns von der Erde zum Gerömo Gerasi Menko bringt. Das ist natürlich das Ideale. Aber das kann man nicht. Und dann können wir nachher gucken, wenn wir die Optimierung durchgeführt haben, geht die Rakete dafür. Ich habe da immer für meine Studenten an der Technischen Universität Darmstadt eine schöne Analogie. Wir leben in der Raumfahrt eigentlich im Zeitalter, wo wir, wenn man es mit der Schifffahrt vergleicht, wo wir mit dem Floß arbeiten. Wir haben keinen Motor, der dauernd läuft, sondern wir stoßen uns einmal ab. Und zwischendurch haben wir auch so einen Stecken, mit dem wir da unten auf dem Flussgrund ein bisschen stochern können. Und wir lassen uns eigentlich, so weit es geht, irgendwie treiben. Die Strömung, sprich Gravitation, nimmt uns schon mit. Aber wir müssen eben dem Floß an gewissen Punkten irgendwie eine Richtung geben, sodass wir in die richtige Strömung kommen, um dann eben da hinzukommen, wo wir hinwollen am Schluss. Und das ist so die Sache, auch wie Rosetta designt wurde. Das ist ganz klar. Wir haben diese Freiheiten geschaffen mit dem Deep Space-Manöver, mit den Flybys. Dann läuft der große Optimierer darüber und gibt uns eine Flugbahn. Und dazu muss man eben Verständnis haben für wie wir so eine Flugbahn, wie wir die Gravitation als Modell implementiert in der Software. Das ist eben die Newtonische Differentialgleichung, wenn man das mathematisch betrachtet, mit allen Gravitationsquellen. Dann wie funktioniert dieses Optimieren? Das ist ja immer ein bisschen ein Problem. Wenn man hochdimensionales Problem hat, findet man oft kein Minimum. Und dann eben diese physikalischen Modelle. Da gehört die Gravitation natürlich auch dazu. Aber der Satellit selber, der ist natürlich irgendwie auch, der kann was passiert, wenn man dem einen Schubs gibt oder der hat dann so ein Lagekontrollsystem und diese Sachen. Das muss natürlich alles dann modelliert werden in der Software.
Wie zeitkritisch ist denn diese Geschichte? Ich meine, da kommt es ja im Prinzip auf die Minute an. Weil, wenn man zu spät auf den Planeten eintaucht, dann ist er schon wieder ein paar Meter weiter und dann zeigt die Bahn, die man da berechnet hat, nicht in die richtige Richtung. Wenn jetzt sich so ein Start verzögert, also man muss ja sozusagen auch irgendwann mal ein Startdatum festlegen und bzw. man spricht ja glaube ich auch von so einem Fenster, sozusagen so ein frühester und ein spittester Zeitpunkt, in dem man noch irgendwie starten kann. Ich weiß nicht, wie groß kann sowas sein?
Das hängt sehr von der Mission ab. Bei Rosetta war es eben so, dass wir einmal im Jahr im Prinzip eine Abfluggelegenheit hatten. Und das ist auch aus praktischem Produkt diese Optimierung.
Einmal im Jahr, aber nicht für beliebig viele Jahre?
Ja, nicht für beliebig viele Jahre.
Sondern wie oft hätte man sozusagen?
Also 2003 war es ideal, um Wirthahn zu erreichen. Man hätte 2004 auch Wirthahn noch erreichen können, wenn das Raumfahrzeugen nicht so schwer gewesen wäre. Und dann hat man gesagt, okay, wir können...
Wann wusste man, dass man diesen Starter nicht halten können würde?
Man wusste vorher schon. Also wenn man es nicht schafft zu starten 2003, dann muss man 2004 zum Turium auf Gerazimenko.
Nee, ich meine aber, wie viele Jahre vorher war klar, dass man dieses Datum nicht halten können würde.
Ach so, das war, ich glaube, der Satellit stand schon auf der Rampe. Man dachte, man könnte starten. Und was dann dazwischen gekommen war, da kann ich mich jetzt gar nicht mehr dran erinnern, ist ja auch schon wieder sieben Jahre her.
Aber wir reden hier von Wochen.
Ja, Wochen.
Das heißt, binnen eines Jahres oder binnen einer weiteren, sehr kurzen Phase, musste man komplett auf einen ganz anderen Kometen...
Ja, das war eigentlich ein ungewohnter Vorgang. Plötzlich musste man dann auch zum anderen Kometen, dann ist das Raumfahrzeug wieder zurück zum SDEC gegangen, weil man musste den Lander dann ein bisschen umbauen für den kleineren Kometen. Das war schon ein bisschen eine schwere Entscheidung.
Was war der Grund, dass man nicht starten konnte?
Das weiß ich leider nicht, müssen wir danach gucken jetzt. Auf jeden Fall hat man...
Man muss sozusagen schnell reagieren. Das ist ja sozusagen sehr umfangreich. Da muss ja jeder im Prinzip nochmal alles überprüfen gelten. Auf dem anderen Kometen dieselben Bedingungen, für die meine Tests und meine Laborequipment etc. vorbereitet sind.
Richtig. Und deswegen hatten wir ja auch... Vornherein hatten wir immer so eine Backup-Mission, nennt sich das. Man bereitet die Mission vor, aber man hat auch immer noch einen Plan B, also eine zweite Mission, die man machen muss, wenn man den Plan A nicht durchführen kann.
Das heißt, der andere Komet war sozusagen schon im Hinterkopf, aber ganz konkret muss man dann schon nochmal...
Umbauen ein bisschen und neu planen. Und jetzt zum Startfenster nochmal, das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Also so ein Start, das ist so typischerweise ein paar Wochen lang, kann man da einmal am Tag starten, manchmal auch monatelang, je nachdem, hängt sehr von der Mission ab. Beim Mars, wenn man zum Mars fliegen will, dann ist es oft nur ein paar Tage, auch wieder abhängig davon, wie kritisch die, wie viel Treibstoff man an Bord hat beim Raumfahrzeug.
Aber hier kann man jetzt auch ganz gut wieder sehen, wie sehr die Planung und die eigentliche Durchführung zusammenhängen, weil in dem Moment, wo man jetzt eigentlich starten wollen würde, und dann kommt irgendwas dazwischen und dann muss man einen Monat später starten, müssen ja im Prinzip diese ganzen neuen Parameter wieder in dieselbe Berechnung fließen. Sonst muss doch alles nochmal neu geplant werden.
Richtig, es wird dann neu geplant und Planung hat ja immer nur eine gewisse Tiefe. Also wir planen zum Beispiel die nominale Mission bis zum Ende durch natürlich, bis alle wirklich jeder kleine Fitzelkram bekannt ist. Und die Backup-Mission, die wird nur bis zu einer gewissen Tiefe geplant, weil man natürlich sonst würde man ja überflüssige Arbeit machen. So und jetzt Überraschung, wir müssen Plan B machen. Und jetzt fängt man diese ganze Arbeit an und sagt, okay jetzt Plan B, aber jetzt muss es wirklich bis zum Ende durch, weil jetzt müssen wir den Plan B fliegen. Und dann dadurch ist diese Verquickung von Betrieb und Planung eigentlich nicht, also das muss ein effizientes Netzwerk sein.
Ist ja auch so, ich meine, es hätte ja auch durchaus sein können, nachdem man den ersten Sattel, den ersten Kometen nicht angeht, dass man dann beim zweiten feststellt, oh holla, um den jetzt zu kriegen, müssen wir ganz anders fliegen. Und jetzt passt auf einmal alles nicht mehr zusammen. Das heißt, das ist im Prinzip von vornherein auch schon berücksichtigt worden. Wir würden es hier jetzt gerne so machen, aber diese und diese Optionskarte können wir gar nicht ziehen. Wenn wir das tun würden, würden wir uns unser Backup vermasseln.
Richtig. Das ist von vornherein im Spacecraft-Design, also wo man das Raumfahrzeug designen wird das schon festgelegt. Es muss so sein, das wird auch überprüft beim Critical Design Review, dass der Satellit in der Lage ist, die Mission und die Backup-Mission zu fliegen. Also man darf zum Beispiel nicht so wenig Treibstoff an Bord bringen. Wenn der Plan B ein bisschen mehr Treibstoff braucht, dann muss eben auch dieser Treibstoff in die Tanks reinpassen. Sonst geht das nicht.
Holler die Waldschwee.
Ja gut, man hat natürlich auch ein paar Jahre Zeit, diese Rechnung zu machen. So eine Phase A dauert meistens so drei, vier Jahre. Und Phase B dauert meistens auch so drei, vier Jahre. Und da hat man natürlich ein bisschen Zeit. Jetzt so in meiner Gruppe, wie gesagt, wir sind zehn Leute. Wir haben natürlich auch eine Menge Missionen im Moment. Das heißt, wir haben, ich würde sagen, so 15 bis 20 Missionen am Bearbeiten. Das heißt, man hat so anderthalb Missionen pro Person. Und in den drei, vier Jahren muss man halt sehen, dass man die Arbeit gemacht kriegt. Es ist eine Menge Arbeit auf dem Schreibtisch, das ist klar.
Bevor wir vielleicht nochmal auf diese unmittelbare Vorbereitung, bevor es losgeht, kommen wir nochmal kurz zu Rosetta. Jetzt vielleicht mal, was jetzt tatsächlich passiert ist. Also 2004 war dann der Start, ein Jahr später. Und dementsprechend halt auch ein anderes Ziel. Und dann ist das Ding gestartet und ist, wenn ich mir die Aktivitätsliste anschaue, ist dann sozusagen von der Erde, also erstmal um die Erde herum.
Nee, direkt abgeflogen.
Direkt abgeflogen und dann zum Mars.
Zum Mars, richtig.
Um da erstmal in eine andere Richtung einzuschlagen.
Ja, also der Mars hat dann Folgendes gemacht.
Der musste erstmal schneller werden oder musste von vornherein eher schon wieder langsamer oder sich sozusagen, ja okay, ich weiß nicht. Also er muss sozusagen eine andere Flugbahn nehmen, um sich der Zielflugbahn anzuwehren.
Und das ist dann auch oft so ein rekoersiver Prozess, nennen das unsere Informatik-Kollegen. Also die Zielsetzung beim Mars-Vorbeiflug war, die die Relativgeschwindigkeit für den nächsten Erdvorbeiflug zu erhöhen. Weil wenn ich schneller an einem anderen Planeten vorbeifliege, habe ich einen größeren Effekt durch den Vorbeiflug. Und weil ich war ja mit der Ariane-Rakete, die war eben beschränkt in ihrer Nutzlast, die konnte dem Rosetta keine große Fluchtgeschwindigkeit geben und musste deswegen diese relativ niederenergetische Bahn zum Mars machen. Der Mars-Vorbeiflug hat uns dann ein bisschen auf eine Flugbahn gebracht, die die Erde in einem großen Erdbein im größeren Winkel schneidet und dadurch hat man eine große Vorbeifluggeschwindigkeit. Das heißt, der darauf folgende Erdvorbeiflug war effizienter. Und der Sinn und Zweck von diesem Erdvorbeiflug war der, den Punkt der Flugbahn, der der Sonne am entferntesten ist, anzuheben. Man hat versucht, weiter weg von der Sonne zu kommen. Weil, um den Kometen draußen beim Jupiter zu treffen, muss man diesen Punkt natürlich immer anheben. Das ist so ein bisschen rekursives Design. Da ist auch ein bisschen Handwerk dabei. Das ist nicht nur Computer, sondern man muss im Prinzip ein Verständnis von den Bewegungen der Planeten haben, um praktisch diese Strategie zu definieren.
Wo wird der Komet dann letzten Endes eingeholt werden?
Beim Jupiter draußen irgendwo.
Beim Jupiter.
Das ist der Abstand, wo er ganz bestimmt noch nicht aktiv ist. Und wo man auch mit einer relativ geringen Relativgeschwindigkeit ankommen kann, weil der Komet selbst sehr langsam ist, relativ zur Sonne gesehen. Und dadurch hat man eben auch diesen Punkt, dass man das Thermaldesign so machen muss. Dass man so weit raus muss, da wird es halt sehr kalt. Und bei dem, es ist halt so, dass man, der Computer kann schon optimieren, aber für Probleme, die sehr empfindlich sind, wie diese Vorbeiflüge. Ich bin da nur so ein paar 100 Kilometer rechts oder links, macht schon einen Riesenunterschied beim Planetenverbeiflug für eine Flugbahn, die im Umfang 100 Millionen Kilometer groß ist. Solche Skalenprobleme kann der Computer nicht gut auflösen. Das heißt, man muss ihm die Strategie vorgeben. Man muss sagen, du fliegst, du musst am Mars vorbeifliegen, um dann an der Erde vorbeizufliegen. Die genauen Details dieser Vorbeiflüge, die kann dann der Computer optimieren.
Letztes Jahr Rosetta auch nicht vollständig untätig gewesen, sondern hat ja auch noch andere Asteroiden passiert. 2008 Stein und in diesem Jahr einen weiteren, Lutetia, das sind dann kleinere Asteroiden, die jetzt...
Na gut, das sind Asteroiden. Wir wollen ja zum Kometen. Also es gibt da, die Wissenschaftler streiten sich noch.
Es sind ja auch nur Steine sozusagen.
Na gut, Kometen sind vielleicht keine Steine, sondern das Bild ist eher so ein schmutziger Schneeball. Ja, also das ist ja bei interplanetaren Missionen gerade so im inneren oder im Bereich der terrestrischen Planeten hat man eben diese Asteroiden. Und eigentlich möchte man die auch sehr genau untersuchen, aber die sind oft nicht attraktiv genug, um wirklich eine Mission dahin zu fliegen.
Sind denn das jetzt Asteroiden, die einfach nur im Asteroidengürtel zwischen Mars und Jupiter sind? Man kommt da sowieso an irgendwelchen vorbei, da war das sozusagen so ein No-Brainer, wenn man da auf diesem Weg ist, dass man das dann irgendwie so mitnimmt.
Ja, ein No-Brainer ist ein bisschen übertrieben. Man hat schon darüber nachgedacht.
Es bietet sich an.
Ja, es bietet sich an. Man hätte jetzt auch die Flugbahn nicht daraufhin designt.
Das war nämlich jetzt eigentlich meine Frage, wie wichtig das war. Man hat gesehen, wir müssen im Prinzip so und so fliegen und da, gucke mal, per Zufall passt es.
Man gibt dann schon ein bisschen Treibstoffe aus, aber nicht sehr viel.
Okay, weil da ist eigentlich immer irgendwas zu holen im Asteroidengürtel, oder?
Richtig. Lutetia war dann der, der ausgewählt wurde, weil er ein bisschen mysteriös war. Man dachte, es ist ein metallischer Asteroid. Und er hatte aber auch Spektralesignaturen von einem steinartigen, stony Asteroid, wie heißt das auf Deutsch? Ein steinartig. Und ja, dadurch haben wir den Vorbeiflug da bekommen. Und soweit ich weiß, ist das noch nicht ganz entschieden jetzt, was der...
Was hat Rosetta sozusagen für Fähigkeiten, dann beim Vorbeiflug da mitzunehmen?
Also da werden erstmal Bilder gemacht, natürlich. Das ist ganz wichtig, dass man zum Beispiel die Oberfläche sagt schon ganz viel aus. Bei der Oberfläche sieht man, ist das ein... Gibt es da viele Krater? Wenn man viele Krater sieht, ist es ein Hinweis darauf, dass er erstens sehr alt ist und zweitens eine harte Oberfläche hat. Dann kann man natürlich einfach durch die Bilder die physikalische Ausdehnung des Objekts bekannt geben. Und unsere Messungen beim Vorbeiflug sagen auch was über die Masse. Wenn man die Masse und das Volumen hat von dem Ding, kann man natürlich die Dichte ausrechnen. Die Dichte sagt, was darüber wir intern aufgebaut ist. Und da kann man eine ganze Menge rausholen aus diesen Vorbeiflügen.
Wird da auch so eine spektrale Aufnahme gemacht?
Ja, genau. Da wird ein Infrarotspektrum gemacht und dann sieht man zum Beispiel welche Mineralien. Die haben gewisse Signaturen, Infrarotsignaturen. Da kann man gucken, ist da Pyroxin oder ist das Oliven? Und das sagt was über die Ursprünglichkeit. Wenn viel Pyroxin drin ist, man weiß es aus dem interstellaren Staub, dann ist es ein sehr ursprüngliches Objekt. Und wenn es mehr so ein Oliven-artiges Objekt ist, dann ist es schon differenzierter. Da haben die Mineralien schon mal ein bisschen eine Differenzierung gesehen. Und das ist ja immer so ein bisschen die Frage, ist so ein Asteroid jetzt ein Fragment von einem Urplaneten, der zerbrochen ist, oder ist so ein Asteroid ein ursprünglicher Teil des Solarniebels, der sich zusammengeballt hat, aber eben noch keinen Planeten gefunden hat, dessen Teil er werden konnte? Und die Untersuchung kann man wunderbar durchführen. Man wird natürlich einen Teufel tun und einfach da vorbeifliegen und die Augen zu machen.
Wie nah kommt man dem?
Das sind ein paar tausend Kilometer, also auswendig weiß ich es jetzt gar nicht.
Das ist ja schon quasi eine Ecke.
Ja, das ist eine Ecke, aber die Kameras sind natürlich auch sehr gut.
Ich meine, so eine astronomische Ecke, also um die Ecke.
Also um die Ecke, ja. Im Vergleich zu ein paar Millionen, 100 Millionen Kilometer, das ist natürlich eine Menge.
Erstaunlich, dass man auf diesen Abständen überhaupt noch so viel erkennen kann.
Ja, die Kameras sind sehr gut und das reicht sicherlich, um die Krater zu zählen.
Keine Atmosphäre auf jeden Fall. So, und danach, nach dem zweiten Vorbeiflug, begab sich die Sonne in einen Deep Space Hibernation. Was ist das denn?
Deep Space Hibernation hört sich fancy an. Also das ist so ein bisschen aus der Not geboren, dass man so eben diesen langen Transfer hat. Und wenn man dann diesen langen Transfer dann auch nimmt, dann gibt es eben auch Zeiten, wo man von der Betriebsseite nicht viel machen muss. Und man möchte natürlich die Kosten minimieren für das Projekt. Und deswegen wird man dahergehen und wird das Team, das hier unten das Raumfahrzeug kontrolliert, runterfahren. Die haben dann in der Zeit andere Dinge zu tun. Hier gibt es genug zu tun im ESOC. Und da hat man dann immer nur einen, der guckt dann alle paar Tage mal rein, ob das Raumfahrzeug noch okay ist. Aber da gibt es kein großes Team. Das ist das, was es bedeutet. Also Hibernation bedeutet einfach Energiesparmodus. Ja, nicht unbedingt Energie, aber Aktivitätsparmodus. Also man hat ja sowieso immer Energie. Die Solarpanele sind ausgefahren. Die Sonne liefert einem Energie. Das ist kein Energieproblem, sondern es ist eine Frage, wie viel man überwachen muss. Genau, wie viel man überwachen muss, so richtig.
Das heißt, es ist eigentlich das Operations Team, was dann in so einem Hibernation-Modus geht. Richtig, die Jungs legen sich ins Bett und schlafen dann zwei Jahre. Ja, so und irgendwann 2014, wenn alles gut läuft, soll dann eben diese Landung durchgeführt werden.
Also die Landung ist cool, super coole Aktion, weil so ein Asteroid- oder Kometenkern, man muss sich vorstellen, wenn man da drauf stünde, könnte man sich durch seine eigene Muskelkraft von dem Ding katapultieren und dann in den Weiten des Weltraums landen. Also der hat so wenig Anziehungskraft, dass die Muskelkraft reicht, sich abzustoßen, um den nie wieder zu sehen. Und das produziert natürlich ein Problem bei der Landung. Was passiert, wenn unser Landegerät da schön abdotzt und sich dann wieder in den Weiten des Weltraums verkrümelt? Das wollen wir natürlich nicht. Deswegen hat er eine Hapune, die schießt er rein in den Kern, die verankert sich und dann holt er die Winde ein. Dann kommt man da praktisch der Oberflächen nah.
Das heißt, man weiß schon genug über die Beschaffenheit. Man glaubt genug zu wissen.
Man versucht das zu designen, hope for the best, plan for the worst. Man hat dann so einen Anker, der sich sowohl im harten Gestein als auch im porösen Gestein verankern kann. Das hat man natürlich getestet. Diese Anker muss natürlich hoffentlich funktionieren. Hoffentlich passiert nicht, dass man da reinschießt und löst dadurch einen Felsen, an dem man sich gerade verankert hat und der fliegt dann mit einem zusammen weg. Da hat man natürlich Pech gehabt. Aber ein bisschen Gravitation ist ja da und man macht das alles sehr langsam. Die Geschwindigkeiten gehen dann runter auf einen Zentimeter pro Sekunde-Bereich. Das ist dann so Fußgängertempo, weniger sogar Schneckentempo. Und wenn man das alles sehr langsam macht, hat man ja die Hoffnung, dass man irgendwie einen Dekometen schon anziehen wird. Das Design ist sehr robust. Das heißt, selbst wenn der Lander der Kopf über drauf landet, dann kann man da noch was machen.
Und dann wird das Labor aktiv. Dann wird ausgewertet, die Daten werden zurückgefunkt. Und dann ist im Prinzip die Mission erfüllt. Und dann bleibt dieses Labor da einfach auf immer und ewig auf diesem Kometen drauf.
Das ist dann genau wie die Landegestelle von den Mondlandefähren. Der Apollo-Astronauten, die stehen ja auch noch auf dem Mond.
Und funkt die dann noch so lange, wie sie kann? Hat das, was landet, auch noch eine eigene Stromversorgung?
Ja, da sind auch Solarpaneele drauf. Es gibt eine vom Programm festgelegte Missionsdauer. Die müssen ja ihr Finanzbudget festlegen und das definiert auch, wie lange die Mission geht. Das heißt dann irgendwann mal 2018, ich weiß es gar nicht genau, im Moment ist der Plan, dann abzuschalten. Selbst wenn das Ding noch funken könnte, wird abgeschaltet. Realität ist natürlich die, wenn man da so ein Labor hat, wird man einen Teufel tun, das abzuschalten. Dann wird man natürlich nach Geld suchen, wird gucken, okay, wollt ihr nicht nochmal ein bisschen was geben, damit wir das noch weiter betreiben können. Dann kommen dann immer diese Extended Missions. Dann erweitert man die Missionen um noch ein paar Jahre.
Wo wird denn der Komet dann sein, 2018? Also hat er sozusagen seinen nächsten Punkt zur Sonne durchschritten?
Ja, genau, er ist dann am Perihel vorbei, der nächsten Punkt heißt Perihel, und hat dann seine aktuelle Phase hinter sich. Und dann kann man eben zum Beispiel gucken, wo sind die Fragmente hin und hin geflogen, die sich gelöst haben aus dem Kometen. Oder man kann eben beobachten, wenn die Aktivität abflaut, wie hat sich die Oberfläche verändert? Also das Modell oder die Idee ist, dass entstehen diese Geysire, die dann eben diese Ausgasung, diese Koma produzieren. Und was passiert jetzt mit der Oberfläche? Ist die dadurch rauer geworden? Ist weniger Eis auf der Oberfläche dadurch jetzt? Und mehr Steine oder was ist da passiert? Das könnte man da noch fragen. Oder es gibt immer Sachen, die man fragen kann.
Einmal rum war 70 Jahre oder so.
Ja, beim Helli. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, beim Chirurgen, Gertrade Menkow, weiß ich nicht.
Aber im Prinzip, wenn das Ding durchhält?
Nee, also ich denke nicht. Also irgendwann ist es auch Schluss wegen der Stromversorgung. Also gerade der Länder hat nicht so große Solarpanele. Und es gibt auch eine relativ große Gefahr, dass der Aktivität selber das Ding praktisch von der Oberfläche hier schockt. Wenn man direkt auf ein Geysir gelandet ist, wenn man Pech gehabt hat, Geysire erkennt man erst, wenn er anfängt zu spucken, dann fliegt man halt damit weg. Also ein bisschen Risiko ist immer dabei.
Bleibt spannend auf jeden Fall. Vielleicht nochmal so zurück zu der eigentlichen Planung. Ich meine, abgesehen davon, dass wir jetzt auch gelernt haben, Planung und dann später die Durchführung, das ist quasi eins. Aber jetzt müssen ja auch noch andere Dinge getan werden. Vor allem, wir haben es vorhin schon mal so ein bisschen angesprochen, so ein Satellit muss eben auch, oder eine Raumsende muss halt getestet werden. Das heißt, wenn das Ding gebaut ist. Was sind denn so die, also wenn jetzt abgeschlossen ist, man weiß, was man haben will. Man hat auch ein konkretes Design. Alle Aufträge sind erfüllt und die Industrie hat gebaut. Wenn sozusagen jetzt die ESA das fertige Gerät in die Hand bekommt, was macht die ESA noch, bis es dann auch wirklich nach Kuro oder wo auch immer gestartet wird, in der Regel ja wahrscheinlich in Kuro. Was wird damit noch gemacht?
Also das ist so ein bisschen so ein ganz weicher Übergang. Die Industrie baut das Ding zwar, aber während die Industrie baut, sind natürlich unsere ESA-Kollegen da schon vor Ort. Die bauen mit. Und dann ist auch dieser Übergang zwischen Bauen und Testen sehr weich. Da wird zusammengebaut, geguckt, passt das alles, prima. Dann bauen wir es wieder auseinander. Dieses Subsystem wird jetzt hier getestet, das Subsystem wird da getestet. Bauen wir es wieder zusammen, machen es in einen Container, bringen es ins S-Tag, bauen es wieder auseinander, testen das mal in dem anderen Test und so weiter.
Aber vor allem ist das S-Tag jetzt hier gefragt.
Genau. Also beim ESOC wird hier für die Hardware kaum was gemacht. Wir sind natürlich involviert, vor allem bei der Software-Validation. Das ist ja ein Software on Board. Und da schicken wir zum Beispiel in einer relativ frühen Phase schon mal Kommandos an den on Board Computer, an die Software. Die muss ja das dann auch bearbeiten können. Da gibt es eben diesen Software-Validation-Test. Da sind wir auch involviert. Aber das passiert alles entweder in S-Tag oder bei unseren industriellen Partnern in Toulouse, in Hamburg, in Bremen, in Madrid, in Stevenage bei London. Oder jetzt habe ich Italien vergessen. Da gibt es in Pardua. Also es gibt eine Menge Standorte. Und dann, so langsam, immer mehr, kommt das Ding im S-Tag zusammen. In diesem großen Testraum im S-Tag. Dann gibt es diese Final Assembly, wird das zusammengebaut. Um zu gucken, insgesamt, jetzt haben wir alle Komponenten zusammen. Zack, alles passt. Dann wird es wieder auseinandergebaut. Und zwar nur zu dem Level, wie es in einen Container muss. Und das ist dann wirklich Aufgabe der ESA-Kollegen, obwohl die Industrie ist natürlich dabei. Das ist klar, die Workforce der Industrie, die Leute, die wirklich da die Schrauben drehen, das sind natürlich zum gewissen Teil nicht vollständig, sind Kollegen aus der Industrie. Auseinandergebaut, in einen Container rein. Und dann geht es wirklich zum Launchpad. Da wird es dann wieder zusammengebaut. Und zwar dann schon in dem Reinraum von Ariane Spass. Die stellen uns dann einen Reinraum zur Verfügung. Und dann wird es dann weiter getestet. Da wird dann zum Beispiel mal geguckt, okay, jetzt hatten wir es auseinander wieder zusammengebaut, falten sich jetzt überhaupt die Solarpanele noch auf. Das wird vorher noch mal getestet. Dann wird es verpackt in der sogenannten Launch Configuration. Und dann kommt ein ganz wichtiger Teil, da wird betankt. Normalerweise haben wir eben chemische Antriebe, dann kommt Hydrazin an Bord. Das ist ein sehr kritischer Vorgang, weil Hydrazin ein Zellgift ist, wo man da sehr vorsichtig mit sein muss. Dann wird es betankt. Wenn es voll ist, kommt es an Bord der Rakete. Und an Bord der Rakete, wenn es dann oben in der Nutzlastverkleidung sitzt, gibt es dann noch mal einen Test. Da wird eben das Interface zwischen der Rakete und dem Raumfahrzeug getestet. Aber auch noch mal durchaus mit einem Onboard-Computer. Man hat dann eben eine Verbindung zum Onboard-Computer. Da werden eben noch mal ein paar Tests gefahren. Und dann muss man auf dem Launchpad selbst auch noch dann... Arianis Bass hat eine grüne Lampe, die den Satelliten repräsentiert. Und nur wenn der seinen Tests erfolgreich durchläuft, ist diese Lampe grün, sonst ist es rot. Und wenn dir noch auf dem Launchpad irgendwas schief geht, mit den Tests vom Onboard-Computer, dann kriegt der auch mal ganz schnell eine rote Fahne. Und dann würde auch der Launch nochmal abgebrochen werden. Spätestens, wenn dann aufs Knöpfchen gedrückt ist und die Booster von der Ariane 5 zünden, dann kann man nichts mehr machen.
Vielleicht nochmal zur Aufgabe der S-Tag. Weil das war jetzt natürlich so, naja, da schiebt man jetzt mal so hin und dann testet man das noch so ein bisschen. Was für Tests müssen denn noch so gemacht werden? Also was wir ja schon erwähnt haben, ist so rütteln und dass alle Komponenten irgendwie funktionieren. Aber wird denn da dann auch diese Mission in irgendeiner Form komplett durch simuliert? Also geht man so diesen ganzen Weg durch? Sondern es geht eigentlich wirklich nur um das Komponententesting?
Nee, also genau. Die Mission selber ist beim Testing eigentlich nur repräsentiert durch die Anforderungen. Also wir haben in der Mission festgelegt, was ist der minimale Sonnenabstand? Okay, im Falle von Rosetta ist es 0,9 astronomische Einheiten. Das heißt, die maximale Hitze, die das Ding abkönnen muss, entspricht so und so viel Watt pro Quadratmeter. Und dann wird in diesem Test auch tatsächlich dieser Sonnensimulator, der eben aus ganz vielen Lampen besteht, der wird eben auf diese Strahlungsleistung hochgefahren, um zu gucken, dass das Ding nicht zu heiß wird.
Plus ein bisschen Spiel wahrscheinlich.
Plus Marge, ist klar, Marge ist immer dabei, weil es könnte mal zum Beispiel ein Thermal Blanket abgehen, so eine Außenverkleidung und dann plötzlich sieht er viel mehr Strahlung als er dachte.
Oder stärkere Sonnenaktivität oder spielt das keine Rolle?
Nee, die Sonne ist sehr konstant. Also in der Gesamtenergiebilanz ist die Sonne sehr konstant. Und dann, also im Prinzip, in den Tests ist die Mission repräsentiert durch diese Anforderungen, diese extremen Anforderungen, diese Worst-Case-Analysis, wie man sie in Euro-Englisch nennt. Und die großen Tests, die da laufen, sind der Thermal-Vakuum-Test. Das ist immer kombiniert. Das heißt, da ist ein Vakuum. Und gleichzeitig werden eben die thermalen Bedingungen, eben die Sonnenstrahlung, simuliert. Dann eben diese Mechanical Load Test, das ist das Rütteln, von dem wir gesprochen haben. Und dann dieser Electromagnetic Test. Da wird dann erst mal getestet, was der Satellit an elektromagnetischen Signalen abgibt. Da muss man auch gegenüber internationalen Regularien kompatibel sein. Man darf zum Beispiel nicht beliebige Funksignale einfach auf die Erdoberfläche bombardieren, sonst könnte man ja hier im Funkverkehr stören. Aber umgekehrt auch, was bedeutet es eigentlich, wenn wir jetzt Störstrahlung von der Sonne haben, Radiowellen, die von der Sonne kommen, in welchem Maße stört das eigentlich den Onboard-Computer? Und dann funktioniert der unter diesen Umständen noch. Das sind so die großen Tests. Da gibt es natürlich Electric Compatibility Tests.
Sonnenwind simuliert.
Ja genau, diese Strahlung ist im weiteren Rahmen Teil vom Sonnenwind. Also was nicht getestet werden kann, sind tatsächlich der Sonnenwind selber, also diese Partikelstrahlung. Da muss man einfach eine Design und eine Analyse machen. Da gibt es physikalische Modelle. Da sagt man dann, okay, wir wissen im interplanetaren Raum gibt es so und so viele Protonen pro Quadratmeter und Sekunde mit so und so einer Energie. Und das hat zur Folge das ionisierende radioaktive Strahlung. Das hat halt einen Effekt auf den Onboard-Computer. Und es wird im Labor manchmal schon die Komponenten einzeln werden getestet. Zum Beispiel der Mikroprozessor, der wird einmal eingespannt in so einen Protonenbeschleuniger und der wird dann mal beschossen und geguckt, wann die Software abstürzt, wenn genug Protonen drauf brutzeln. Aber der Satellit selber nicht mehr.
Und welche Tests jetzt konkret durchgeführt werden, das bestimmt aber das ESSEC selbst, oder?
Das ist in einer Prozedur vorgeschrieben. Da gibt es Standards, Industriestandards, ECSS ist das Stichwort, European Committee for Space Standardization, heißt die Organisation, die diese festlegt. Und da gibt es eben so Standards und Prozeduren. Und das ist eigentlich alles klar von vornherein. Da muss man nicht drüber nachdenken.
Und wie ist so die Ausschussquote? Wie viele Fehlern kommt man da beim ESSEC so auf die Spur? Ist das eher viel oder ist das irgendwie, man freut sich, wenn man mal was gefunden hat, weil eigentlich ist immer alles so toll, dass es gleich funktioniert?
Also da habe ich nicht so viele Einsichten rein. Ich sehe es halt immer nur, wenn es dann auf meine Arbeit Rückwirkung hat. Und das passiert nicht selten. Also wir hatten jetzt mal einen Test bei einer Mission, die nennt sich Gaia, also eine Astronomie-Mission, ganz toll eigentlich. Und da hat man so ein Lage-Kontrollsystem, das arbeitet mit Druckgas. Und da hat man festgestellt, dass dieses Druckgas-Kontrollsystem, das ist auch ein Antriebssystem, das für die Lage des Satelliten verantwortlich ist, nicht so effizient arbeitet. Das heißt, um eine gewisse Lagekorrektur zu erzeugen, braucht es mehr Treibstoff, als wir dachten, im Sinne von Kilogramm an Druckgas. Und das hat der Test bewiesen, dass praktisch das System diesen Anforderungen nicht genügt. Und man kann natürlich, im Prinzip ist man da in einer Zwickmühle, man kann natürlich dem Lieferanten nicht sagen, hör mal zu, du hast diese Anforderungen nicht erfüllt, reparier es auf deine Kosten oder du verlierst den ganzen Auftrag. Weil dann ist die Mission zu Ende oder unter Umständen treibt man das Unternehmen in den Bankrott, was natürlich auch nicht der Zweck der ESA ist. Und deswegen wird dann nach anderen Möglichkeiten gesucht. Es gibt dann einen Waiver, wo man dann sagt, ja okay, es wird akzeptiert, dass diese Anforderung nicht erfüllt ist. Und was kann man von der Missionsseite aus machen, um dann trotzdem doch eine Mission noch zu haben? Und da war unsere Idee dann, ja wir können eben zum Beispiel bei der Lagehaltung, während das Ding dann im Betriebsorbet ist, kann man durch eine Verbesserung der Navigation erreichen, dass diese Lagerhaltungsmanöver mit dem geringeren Treibstoffbedarf zurechtkommen. Das ist dann eine weitere Optimierung.
Das heißt, die Testergebnisse haben nicht selten konkreten Einfluss auf die Details der Missionsplanung, womit man dann wieder ein paar Parameter anders einstellen muss. Das heißt, auch in der Phase ist die Missionsplanung eigentlich sehr fest verwoben mit der Arbeit der ASTEC, genauso wie später eben mit den Operations.
Richtig, weil es passiert eigentlich fast monatlich, dass was Neues kommt. Weil wir treiben diese Technologie eben bis an die Wand. Das sind typischerweise die wissenschaftlichen Anforderungen. Die Wissenschaft muss zehnmal so gut sein wie die Wissenschaft der letzten Mission. Sonst lohnt sich die Mission nicht. Das Budget ist meistens maximal zehn Prozent mehr wie die letzte Mission. Also muss mit demselben Geld zehnmal so gut sein. Das bedeutet, die Hardware wird unheimlich an die Wand getrieben. Also der Speicher muss viel besser sein, viel mehr Speicher an Bord. Die Batterien müssen viel länger durchhalten. Die Triebwerke müssen viel genauer sein und so weiter. Und jetzt hatte ich auch ein anderes Beispiel, das ist auch wieder mit dem Triebwerk, ein hochpräzises Triebwerk, das hat diese Präzisionsanforderungen erfüllt, aber es stellte sich im Test raus, dass der Schub viel geringer ist als verdachten. Und da muss man auch wieder ein Missionsdesign neu machen. Und da in der Phase sind wir sehr eng mit den ESD-Kollegen zusammen.
Die ganze Truppe, die jetzt hier in dieser Missionsplanung arbeitet, was für Wissenschaftler sind denn das eigentlich? Was muss man denn so an Ausbildung da mit einbringen? Oder woraus setzt sich das zusammen?
Das ist eine sehr bunte Truppe. Wir haben so ein geflügeltes Wort bei uns. Missionsanalytiker wachsen nicht auf den Bäumen. Man kann Missionsanalyse nicht an der Uni studieren, sondern wir nehmen diplomierte Ingenieure, diplomierte Mathematiker und Naturwissenschaftler und lassen die bei uns arbeiten. Im Rahmen dieser Arbeit lernt man diese Fähigkeiten. Das ist wirklich ein akademischer Charakter, was das angeht. Die Arbeit und die Ausbildung kann man nicht auseinanderreißen. Typischerweise, mein Chef ist Mathematiker, das ist der Johannes Gunmarkers. Meine Kollegen sind zum großen Teil Ingenieure. Ein paar sind Mathematiker. Was sind die Ingenieure jetzt? Maschinenbau und Kommunikationstechnik. Ein paar sind auch Luft- und Raumfahrtingenieure. Die meisten diplomieren, manche promovieren, manche können sogar im Rahmen der Arbeit hier eine Promotion machen. Ich selber bin der einzige Naturwissenschaftler, ich bin Doktor der Physik. Was mich so ein bisschen zum Exot macht in der Gruppe, weil Naturwissenschaftler per se immer ein bisschen andere Herangehensweise haben an Probleme wie Mathematiker und Ingenieure. Wir sind sehr breit aufgestellt und wir blicken das von der Anforderungsanalyse bis zum optimierten Bahn. Das ist unsere Stärke, unsere Schwäche ist allerdings dann im Lesen von Dokumenten. Wir haben immer das Problem, dass wir die kleinen Details uns durch die Finger schlüpfen. Das liegt irgendwie an unseren Naturwissenschaftlern.
Das macht sozusagen den Ingenieur auch so geeignet für den Job.
Ja, genau. Der Ingenieur ist von seiner Ausbildung oder von ihrer Ausbildung her sehr darauf bedacht, wirklich eins zu eins umzusetzen, was in der Blaupause steht. Die haben so diesen Weg, Blaupause, und ich bau daraus eine Maschine. Das wird einem als Naturwissenschaftler natürlich überhaupt nicht beigebracht. Da habe ich auch eine ganz klare Schwäche, die ich auch immer kommunizieren muss.
Das ist es ja eigentlich, was man macht. Man baut eine Maschine, die geht aber weit über die physikalische Greifbarkeit der Maschine selbst hinaus. Das ist eigentlich die gesamte, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, Himmelsmechanik, die man an der Stelle quasi mit in dieses Produkt einfließen lässt. Denn nur in dem Kontext des gesamten Verlaufs erfüllt das Ganze überhaupt erst seine Bestimmung.
Genau, also dieses Aluminiumding Rosetta funktioniert auch nur im Sonnensystem. Das würde nirgendwo anders funktionieren. Also das Sonnensystem selbst ist Teil der Maschine.
Und auch nur an einem kleinen Teil dieses Sonnensystems.
Richtig, absolut.
Und lässt sich auch so nie wieder für irgendetwas anderes, also abgesehen davon, dass man es eh nicht zurückkriegt.
Also man macht natürlich dann, man nutzt es natürlich. Aus Rosetta ist Mars Express hervorgegangen, weil Mars Express fliegt zu Mars. Also da sind sogar die Anforderungen ein bisschen weniger hart. Und man konnte zum Beispiel ein Onboard-Computer, dieser ganze Spacecraft-Bus, der wurde übernommen. Und das hat eine Menge Vorteile. Nicht nur die Tatsache, dass man das Ding einfach dreimal bauen kann und dann get three for the price of two.
Man hat auch die ganzen Simulationsdaten und Algorithmen bereits.
Deswegen haben wir zum Beispiel einen Kontrollraum. Da wird Rosetta, Mars Express und Venus Express gesteuert. Man macht also dreimal eine tolle Mission, drei verschiedene tolle Wissenschaftsmissionen für den Preis von einer oder für den Preis von andern Teil. Und wir sind natürlich angehalten, Steuergelder mit höchstmöglicher Effizienz auszugeben. Und wir haben da wirklich eine Reputation bei der ESA, aus einem Steuer Euro 3 zu machen. Also das kriegen wir schon hin.
Und es ist natürlich auch, wenn man sich das z.B. im Computerbereich anschaut, dann machen Standardisierung immer Sinn, weil sich das Wissen besser übertragen. Das ist ja auch eine Frage der Ausbildung, ist ja auch eine Frage der persönlichen Vertiefung in solche Systeme und damit natürlich auch der Erfahrung. Weil man ja dann auch das Krisenmanagement von der einen Mission auf die andere Mission vielleicht besser übertragen kann. Das ist natürlich immer noch eine andere Geschichte. Unterscheiden sich denn jetzt, wir haben Rosetta als das große Beispiel genannt, und das ist halt so Raumsonne, das heißt, ab ins Weltall, irgendwo hin, und da bleiben wir dann auch, und wenn es irgendwie noch besser und glücklicher gelaufen wäre, hätten wir vielleicht auch noch mal wieder was zurückgeholt. Jetzt sind ja solche Missionen wie Mars Express und Winix, also solche Explorer-Missionen und Vermessungssachen. Ist das jetzt was anderes, oder ähnelt sich die Missionsplanung eigentlich immer?
Die ähnelt sich schon sehr. Also solche großen Missionen wie Rosetta sind natürlich oft komplexer, weil die Anforderungskatalogen länger sind.
Was macht das groß?
Groß, oft ist Geld einfach. Groß bedeutet, man hat am Anfang mal gedacht, da haben wir 500 Millionen Euro für. Da wollen wir dann auch ordentlich was draufstopfen. Dann kommen dann statt drei Instrumente plötzlich zehn an Bord. Dann ist natürlich der Anforderungskatalog länger. Das Ding muss mehr können. Es kann auch mehr schiefgehen, kommt eine höhere Komplexität. Dann kommt eine große Masse plötzlich zustande, natürlich weil die ganzen Instrumente drauf sind. Hat man nicht mehr viel Masse für den Treibstoff, dann muss man kreativer werden bei dieser Flugbahn. Dann muss man mehr die Schwung der Planeten benutzen. Bei Mars Express, das ist einfach, sagt schon der Name Express, ist ein bisschen hervorgegangen aus der Tatsache, dass man eine Mars-Mission mal verloren hatte, die Mars 96-Mission mit den russischen Kollegen zusammen. Da sagte man, okay, jetzt wollen wir schnell das selbe machen, aber nicht mit den Russen zusammen, weil die haben im Moment kein Geld. Wir machen selber. Dann sollte innerhalb von 96 bis 2003, das waren eben nur sieben Jahre, zack, muss das Ding definiert sein. Und dann muss es jetzt ein bisschen hurtig gehen. Und da war natürlich der Augenmerk darauf, nicht so kompliziert machen, einfacher. Um sowieso zu Mars zu fliegen, da hat man nicht so viele Möglichkeiten mit Flybys. Zwischen Erde und Mars gibt es halt keinen Planeten. Muss man ein bisschen vereinfacht zu sagen. Und da hat man das alles sehr einfach gehalten. Und das erzeugt bei uns auch weniger Aufwand. Natürlich, ganz klar. Aber im Prinzip, solche interplanetaren Missionen sind oft sehr ähnlich. Missionsdesign, aber auch vom Spacecraft-Design. Sehr anders wird es halt am Bereich Erdbeobachtung. Die haben dann ganz andere Anforderungskatalog oder Kommunikationssatelliten oder Navigationssatelliten. Das Engineering davon ist dann oft ein ganz anderes.
Aber die Laufzeiten sind dann natürlich auch teilweise viel länger.
Laufzeiten im Sinne von Signallaufzeiten?
Im Sinne, wie lange bringt es so laufen?
Ja, absolut. Galileo bedeutet auch teilweise, meine Galileo, das Navigationssystem soll ja über Jahrzehnte betrieben werden. Da soll man ja auch noch in 50 Jahren was von haben. Und in solchen Maßstäben denkt man bei den interplanetaren Missionen eigentlich nicht.
Ist natürlich alles ein bisschen schwer zu vergleichen, aber so von den Missionen der letzten 10, 20 Jahre, was waren denn so die größten Herausforderungen unter dem Gesichtspunkt Missionsplanung? Oder sagen wir mal jetzt vielleicht auch vielleicht dann und damit ja sozusagen auch für die ESA insgesamt?
Da fällt sicherlich Rosetta rein in die Kategorie der Milestones oder der Key Missions wegen der Komplexität des interplanetaren Transfers. Zum Thema Komplex, die haben aber nicht nur große Missionen, sondern gerade die kleinen sind es oft, die dann plötzlich eine ganz verrückte Mission fordern, weil man das auf der anderen Seite beim Spacecraft Design so weit eingeschränkt hat. Da wäre zu nennen Smart 1 zum Mond. Smart 1 war ein interessantes Projekt. Man wollte mal einen anderen Antrieb probieren, einfach eine Technologie-Demonstratormission, einen Ionenantrieb zu fliegen. Da werden statt Hydrazin mit Tetra-Stückstoff, weiß jetzt gar nicht, Perxyl-Stückstoff, Perxyl zu verbrennen, wird da eben elektrisch geladen Teilchen hinten raus beschleunigt. Das ist viel effizienter, hat aber eine höhere, der Antrieb selber hat eine höhere Masse. Das ist also ein bisschen so ein Trade-Off, man muss überlegen, was man macht. Das wollten wir aber mal im Einsatz testen. Da wollte man erst zu den Asteroiden fliegen, also sprich mit der Ariane starten, und dann diesen Ionenantrieb setzen, um die Bahn langsam so zu verändern, dass man zum Asteroiden kommt. Da hat es mal einen draufgekommen, das klappt nicht. Da ist die Masse zu hoch, also müssen wir zum Mond fliegen. Im Mond ist eben mit einer kleineren Masseaufwand zu erreichen. Und das Problem ist aber dann, dass man manövrieren muss von der Erde zum Mond. Und man hatte, um Kosten zu sparen, sich als Passagier auf einen kommerziellen Ariane-Flug draufgesetzt. Und war praktisch auf so einer Bahn, eine Flugbahn, die zum geostationären Orbit ging, da wo die ganzen TV-Satelliten sind. Und der ist ja 36.000 Kilometer, ist ja der entfernteste Punkt von dieser Bahn. Und man musste zum Mond, also 384.000 Kilometer.
Und auch wieder die notwendige Geschwindigkeit haben, um die Erde überhaupt erst mal verlassen zu können.
Das brauchen wir nicht. Der Mond ist ja im Gravitations- Einflussbereich der Erde. Jedenfalls, das Ding war, man hatte nur diesen Antrieb. Man hatte kaum noch starke Düsen. Und der hatte einen sehr geringen Schub. Und das ist ein ganz, mathematisch gesehen ein ganz anderes Problem. Da hat man eben nicht mehr diesen Effekt wie beim Floß. Ich stoße mich einmal ab und lasse mich dann treiben, sondern ich habe wirklich einen Motor, der dauernd läuft. Allerdings einen sehr schwachen Motor. So ein bisschen wie ein, was weiß ich, kennt man ja manchmal auf den Szenen, gibt es so kleine Elektromotorboote.
Ist ungefähr so, als ob man so auf so einem größeren Schiff ist und dann hinten so ein paar Ventilatoren hat, die man irgendwie so zuschalten kann.
Richtig, so in die Richtung. Und dann versuchte man, sich da zurechtzufinden. Und die Bahnoptimierung von der Bahn wäre sehr interessant. Also Smart 1 fällt in diese Kategorie dieser Key Missions.
Hat aber geklappt.
Hat geklappt, ja.
Ist zum Mond gekommen.
Hat sogar alles übertroffen, was wir wollten. Also hat dann nicht nur diese Technologie demonstriert, sondern auch noch wissenschaftliche Resultate gesammelt, was natürlich unheimlich, das war so ein Bonus, den man mitgenommen hat.
Jetzt in Bezug auf den Antrieb oder in Bezug auf den Mond?
In Bezug auf den Mond auch dann. Man hat natürlich eine Kamera mitgenommen, wenn man schon mal dahin fliegt. Und dann hat man am Schluss, wenn man in einer Umlaufbahn und Mond ist, lässt sich nicht vermeiden, dass man irgendwann mal auf der Oberfläche zerschält. Und dann hat man diesen Einschlag so geplant, dass man auf dem Südpol einschlägt.
Warum lässt sich das nicht vermeiden?
Weil der Mond ein inhomogenes Gravitationsfeld hat und die Flugbahn natürlich sich so verändert. Die wird immer exzentrischer, sodass der Mond den nächsten Punkt immer niedriger wird, bis er irgendwann mal die Oberfläche kommt.
Also man eiert sozusagen.
Man eiert immer schlimmer und dann bang. Und dann hat man es eben so geplant, dass man auf den Südpol einschlägt. Und das ist eine ganz interessante Region auf dem Mond, wo man in der Zukunft vielleicht sogar mal eine Mondbasis errichten möchte, weil es dort Wasser gibt, wenn man jetzt weiß. Und das war so ein Teil dieser wissenschaftlichen Untersuchung.
Ach so, hat der SmartUp rausgefunden.
Ja, das war vorher ein bisschen bekannt. Noch nicht so hundertprozentig. Und ist eigentlich seit einer Woche, weil letzte Woche große Wissenschaftsneuigkeiten ist, hat man es endgültig festgenagelt, bewiesen, mit Hilfe der NASA-Sonde LCROSS. Aber Smart1 hat da wichtige Vorarbeit geleistet. Und das sind jetzt so die Planeten. Natürlich hat die ESA noch einen ganz wichtigen Teil, nämlich die Astronomie. Eine der weltweit bekanntesten Astronomie-Missionen. Natürlich Hubble, jeder kennt das Hubble Space Teleskop. Da hat die ESA 15% Anteil dran. Das wird oft auch vergessen. Das ist nicht nur ein NASA-Projekt. Aber eine ganz wichtige Mission, die in der Öffentlichkeit nicht so bekannt ist, ist Hipparchos. Hipparchos ist die Mission, die weltweit... Also unsere Himmelskarten, die Karten, die wir vom Himmel haben, die kommen von Hipparchos. Und das ist eine Mission, die ist in 80er Jahren geflogen. Die hat den Himmel vermessen. Und kurz nach dem Start war relativ schnell klar, dass die Mission ein Riesenproblem hat. Man wollte nämlich in geostationären Orbit, wie gesagt, da, wo die TV-Sateliten sind, damit man ein schön ruhiges Umgebung hat, da schön langsam kreisen kann, um da Bilder vom Sternenhimmel zu machen. Man hat herausgefunden, dass der Apogäumsmotor kaputt ist. Man kann also... Man war auf dieser Bahn, die die Rakete einen eingeschossen hat, auf so einer elliptischen Bahn, mit dem Apogäum beim geostationären Punkt. Das ist der Raketenantrieb von einem Satelliten, der dafür sorgt, dass es, nachdem er von der Rakete gestartet wurde, in diese geostationäre Kreisbahn kommt.
Okay.
Der macht dieses eine Manöver, dafür ist er da. Deswegen heißt er Apogäum-Motor. Und jetzt ist er von dieser Startbahn der Rakete, die zwar stabil war, aber eben nicht in dieser schönen gleichmäßigen Kreisbahn, sondern eben in der hoche elliptischen Bahn. Mussten wir das umdesignen, dass er eben auf dieser elliptischen Bahn auch seine wissenschaftlichen Anforderungen erfüllen kann. Da haben wir eben langsam mit den Kontrolldüsen das Apogäum weiter angehoben, also dass er dann eben weit weg war und hat da viel Zeit dort am erdentfernten Punkt verbracht. Und man hatte da ein bisschen Zeit immer wieder unterbrochen, natürlich dadurch, dass man zurückfiel zur Erde, aber nicht wieder eintritt, sondern eben dann einmal rum und wieder hoch.
Also man hat sozusagen diese Ellipse, man konnte sie nicht komplett zum Kreis machen, aber man konnte sie zumindest den maximalen Abstand zur Erde minimal halten.
Man könnte den maximalen Abstand erhöhen sogar noch, um dann statt gleichmäßig auf einem Kreis praktisch an diesem entfernten Punkt lange zu fahren. Das war die Strategie. Und gleichzeitig den nächsten Punkt auch ein bisschen anzuheben, damit man nicht so nahe in die Erde kommt. Und dadurch haben wir die Mission gerettet und wir konnten tatsächlich diesen unglaublichen Sternenkatalog tatsächlich dann auch erreichen. Und heute jeder Astronom kennt den Hipparkos-Katalog. Und das war auch sicherlich, fällt da Hipparkos auch in diese Schublade, der ESA Keystone Missions.
Ja, obwohl das eigentlich gar nicht so bekannt ist. Das ist kein Name, der häufig fällt. Ich meine, gerade bei der Weltraumbeeobachtung und ich meine, wenn das in der Ergebnis sozusagen so ein Katalog ist, dann ist das natürlich im Wesentlichen so ein bisschen Science-Porn. Natürlich nicht so attraktiv, wie jetzt auf einem anderen Planeten rumzufahren. Aber solche Missionen sind natürlich eben auch sehr wichtig zumal ja eben die ganzen Erkenntnisse auch immer wieder aufeinander aufbauen und dann eben auch die entsprechende Basis für andere Missionen geben. Ja, das war ja schon ein sehr umfangreicher Exkurs. Haben wir irgendwas ganz Wichtiges ausgelassen?
Bestimmt, aber dann wird man hier morgen noch sitzen. Ja, das waren schon mal ganz aufregende Highlights eigentlich.
Was bringt so die Naher Zukunft?
Die Naher Zukunft heißt Cosmic Vision. Das ist das Programm, und ich arbeite persönlich hauptsächlich an diesen Weltraumteleskopen. Da sind wir jetzt in der dritten Generation der Weltraumteleskope und die definieren wir gerade ganz spannend eigentlich. Da gibt es Missionen, die dafür designed sind, andere Welten, andere Erden zu finden. Also Exoplaneten, die erdähnlich sind. Da gibt es Missionen, die das Geheimnis der dunklen Energie auf die Pferde kommen wollen. Dann gibt es Missionen, die Gravitationswellen nachweisen wollen. Also es gibt da unheimlich... Wir sind, glaube ich, gerade, was die Wissenschaft, die Weltraumforschung angeht, in so einem unheimlichen Schub. Das passiert unheimlich viel. Wir haben zum Beispiel in den letzten 15 Jahren 400 Planeten entdeckt, irgendwo in der Nähe unserer näheren galaktischen Umgebung. Also da passiert eine ganze Menge.
Und auch schon die ersten erdähnlichen.
Ja, also der erste erdähnliche, Anführungszeichen, oben. Da wird immer ein bisschen gemogelt, wenn man erdähnlich sagt, weil sich dann natürlich das gut verkauft. So richtig erdähnlich ist der nicht, aber so von Temperaturen kommt er schon mal ganz gut ran.
Erkenntnisdichte ist auf jeden Fall enorm und lässt einfach wieder viele neue Missionen zu.
Man denkt immer so, wenn man so mal auf den üblichen High-Tech-Medien liest, auch im Web 2.0 durchaus, denkt man immer so ein bisschen, in der IT passiert unheimlich viel. Aber eigentlich stimmt das nicht. Das ist so ein bisschen verzerrte Kommunikation. Es passiert unheimlich viel in der Naturwissenschaft im Moment.
Weil einfach die Erkenntnislage, vor allem die Grundlagenforschung erheblich vorangekommen ist? Absolut.
Also die Grundlagenforschung ist da so ein Wegbereiter. Man hat viele Theorien aufgestellt. Und jetzt sind wir in einem Zeitalter, wo plötzlich Daten kommen. Und das ist immer so. Wenn man plötzlich dann gibt es so eine Kollision der Wirklichkeit mit dem, was man so dachte, und dann gibt es ein großes Feuerwerk. Und da sind wir jetzt gerade dabei, das Feuerwerk anzugucken. Es ist natürlich auch schwer zu kommunizieren, weil ich meine, die Oberflächenbeschaffenheit des Saturn-Mondes Titan, um die zu schätzen, um diesen Science-Porn auch mal zu genießen, muss man natürlich gewisse Grundlagen verstehen. Was bedeutet eigentlich Titan? Was ist das für einer? Was hat der mit mir zu tun, der Saturn-Mond Titan? Jeder denkt, er hätte eine gewisse intime Beziehung zu einem neuen Prozessor, der von einer großen US-amerikanischen Firma rausgebracht wird, aber niemand hat eine emotionale Beziehung zu einem gewissen chemischen Compound, der irgendwie auf einer Oberfläche eines Mondes entdeckt wird.
Naja, vielleicht kriegen wir das ja hier geändert im Raumzeit-Podcast. Genau. Darum geht es ja hier, ein bisschen tiefer einzutauchen in die Details, die sonst vielleicht am Rande liegen bleiben. Insofern, vielen Dank Markus, Markus Landgraf. Schöner Einblick in Missionsplanung und die ganze Vorbereitung, die reingesteckt werden muss, bevor man überhaupt erst mal darüber nachdenken kann, irgendwas in eine Rakete zu stecken. In der nächsten Ausgabe werden wir uns mal anschauen, wie das genau funktioniert. Ja, und danke.
Ich danke dir Tim, es war sehr angenehm.
Ja, ich habe es auch genossen und ich hoffe, es ging auch allen höher an so. Und jetzt bleibt mir nur noch einen schönen Tag zu wünschen und zu hoffen, dass ihr auch das nächste Mal wieder einschaltet, hier bei Raumzeiten. Bis bald, tschüss.